foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
end game we've added a new
classification called Miss for when a
move fails to take advantage of an
opportunity but it is otherwise a sound
move we've also changed the definition
of blunder now a move will only be
considered a blunder if it loses
material or allows a checkmate coach
will now draw arrows and highlight
squares when you hover over or click on
the highlighted words in the move
explanation this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on chess.com
right now
oh my goodness Knight d8 whoa Bishop G5
oh no
[Music]
foreign
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh donoraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and Shakira Mami
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
hello and it's round three of Norway
chess and I can feel it in my fingers
it's gonna be another electrifying day
of Chess as the world's finest players
gather here in the Magnificent playing
Hall in Stavanger it's gonna be another
great day of action all I can say is
buckle up and let the games begin I'm
your host International master and it is
a great pleasure to be here in the
studio calling all the action alongside
the Legendary Super Grand Master Judith
Polgar
and of course we have regular
Grandmaster David Howell in the studio
with us good
my pleasure David and dude yesterday it
was such a dramatic day what who
impressed you the most
it was an amazing day I must say I will
remember that day for a long time I
believe but if I have to pick one game I
would say that I was it was very special
for me to see the underdog tari
completely out playing up to satirov who
is the great talent and because the
opening was just so crazy that I
couldn't believe that it's really
standing on the board so that was one of
the most interesting game for me and for
you David were there any surprises I'm
not sure about surprises just drama just
the fact that there were brilliancies on
the board as Juliet mentioned blunders
on the board everywhere for me the
Highlight was potentially that
Armageddon game between Magnus Carlsen
and Wesley so where Magnus was in deep
deep trouble but managed to turn things
around when he really needed to and pull
his first points out of the bag in the
tournament and uh yes he did get on to
the scoreboard and let's take a recap of
yesterday's results
and after two days of Chess it's a lot
of excitement and there we can see
Magnus Carlson and Wesley so well it was
Magnus Carlson that walked away with
those important points after winning in
the Armageddon but there were a lot of
surprises and a lot of decisive results
in the classical portion anything that
caught your eye dude it
oh there are a lot of things as I
mentioned before but for example for me
it was exceptionally interesting how
Magnus outplayed in a second from a very
bad position Wesley so in the Armageddon
I mean that was really incredible to
follow how fast and and it was a shock
for me that it was it seemed so easy for
Magnus to win out of a very bad position
hey that was an incredible game and
David what about these results do
anything surprise you surprise you well
I'm not sure about surprises but uh just
the number of decisive games we've seen
five decisive games out of 10 so far in
the first two rounds in the classical
portion that's a quite high percentage
at this elevated level and of course the
armageddons have led to a lot of
entertainment there and maybe what
surprised me has been how the players
have struggled to adapt to the different
time controls often we do see the Panic
setting at quite an early stage yes and
uh one person who did walk away from a
round two with a big smile on their face
was Hikaru Nakamura as he defeated
gukash in their classical encounter with
the black pieces after the game he
caught up with our reporter svera and
let's find out his thoughts
that was quite the hectic finish to this
game you got a yeah I mean it was a very
strange game but I I think you know we
both had chances at some point uh well
you guys saw me go in the Box I mean
basically in the opening I decided to
play the C takes D4 which I suspect is
slightly dubious but it creates an
isolated Palm position which I think
means they're gonna be more chances for
either of us to win the game because
there's an imbalance um and I thought
good cash played great I thought A4 was
a very good move I think maybe bishop B1
wasn't right I I have a feeling again
from the confessional box like I have a
feeling I'm gonna look at this and
there's like a moment of like two to
three moves where probably he had a
couple ways that were winning but in
human play at least I don't think we'd
figure it out I mean you guys know was
it winning for it not at that point no
it wasn't but it was winning at some
point right well to be honest I didn't
catch at that moment so but I I I I did
though see your confessionals were were
even though it wasn't making a huge
computer difference at that point it did
change the dynamic somehow how does that
change I mean going into being a player
in a super tournament a commentator and
a streamer at the same time yeah well I
mean the good thing is there's a lot of
time to think a lot of time to talk and
do all these things but yeah I think in
the game I mean the thing is it was
probably like I felt like for a couple
of moves he had this chances when he
didn't take advantage of his chances
then it started going the other way and
I mean I don't think I was ever like
much better but then as we started
getting low on time I got the sense that
goukash really wanted to play on and not
make a draw and um I just kept finding
moves and of course then much like the
last couple of days I found a way in
this time screen will make it very very
messy I mean I think there should have
been a clean way to be close to winning
and then I mean I allowed this bishop E2
I was very lucky I had Queen E4 after
the game we're talking about this bishop
F1 move which is also a possibility
um but it just it started spiraling
wildly out of control but you know
considering yesterday the lock wasn't on
my side when I very clearly should not
have lost Armageddon game to Wesley it
all balances out
thank you so much for great
entertainment and just as a
clarification you don't have to write
notes at the end
ah you don't but you're getting 10
second increment I mean yeah it would
have to be a half a minute for you to
have to write
really okay that's that's news to me I
thought it was five seconds but okay
whatever it's all good yeah
and there we see Hikaru talking about
fighting chairs things getting out of
control somewhat in the game and so
perhaps surprise surprisingly not
knowing the rules he didn't need to
notate well I hope that the the other
players also will get the an information
like this because now in the camera is
an advantage
but it happens time to time and of
course it's very difficult to follow all
these different time controls and I
think it's very difficult to change your
mindset also especially that the players
when they reach down to seconds they
know here that there's no extra 15
minutes for the rest of the game no they
have to live with these seconds only so
probably the routine that they are
writing the moves it's still there so
even if they know maybe some of them can
forget about this because it's just the
tension is so high yeah and what about
you David what did you make of that
interview I'm not surprised that Hikaru
wasn't familiar with the rules the place
have to adapt now to so many different
time controls every tournament it's a
different time control and uh yeah
players have never read the regulations
I remember in OHS one year Magnus
Carlsen lost on time he allowed his
clock to run out against apollov because
he hadn't read the rules he assumed he
would get more time and that wasn't the
case so it's not the first time that's
happened and uh Hikaru should be glad
that he knows now for the future he
certainly does it's certainly knowledge
gained and in the meantime let's take a
look at the standings after two rounds
of Norway chess and we can see right
there at the top it is Fabiana caruana
he won one classical game and also one
game in the Armageddon and that takes
him up to four and a half points out of
six and then we have Hikaru Nakamura and
nordebec abdisator of chasing down that
small lead with four points out of six
but if we work our way down to the
bottom bottom of the table we can see
that Magnus Carlson there on eighth
place which is one and a half points out
of six he definitely needs to start
winning some games in the classical
section and talking about classical
section and talking about today's
matches there is a big one coming your
way Hikaru Nakamura will be playing with
the white pieces against none other than
Magnus Carlson and that is probably the
biggest match so far but Judy what other
matches catch your eyes well indeed of
course Hikaru Magnus that will be kind
of a special match and I think the world
is keeping an eye on that not only we
are but for me it's going to be very
interesting to see gokash the newcomer
the youngster to play against the Old
Timer who is of course not old but he's
there for like 20 years almost in the
top and to see them how they will play
out today after a loss yesterday they
both lost in a classical game they both
Mama jaro for example had a fantastic
position he was much better so it's
really painful to lose that position
what he lost against firoza and the
gokash also had some chances very
dramatic game against Nakamura so I'm
really really interested how they are
going to bounce back yeah I'm interested
too the emotions are going to be running
high and David
for you yeah it's The Clash of the
Titans The Clash of the teenagers for me
uh nordeback Abdul toroff against
alireza farouza 18 years old against 19
years old it's uh but two players in
form as well both having won yesterday
in the classical portion and yeah I have
a fee feeling one of the two will be a
world champion someday I can't wait to
follow that game I can't wait today as
well but anyhow Norway chess it is the
home of Fighting Chess and that's
because it pushes the boundaries a
little bit and we have a rather unique
tournament format it's a 10 player
single round robin and here is where it
gets a bit interesting 120 minutes for
the entire game but there will not be
any increment until after move 40 and
upon which the players will be getting
10 seconds and in the event of a draw
it's when things get fast and furious
because Armageddon will break that tie
and of course it's Fighting Chess so no
draw offers allowed before move 30 oh oh
I think it's I think this type of format
should be introduced for most classical
events I know already more and more
people are telling me friends messaging
me that wow this is so cool to have this
decisive games all the time but this is
kind of tricky also that they are not
allowed to make a draw before move 30
and yesterday we've seen Wesley so
offering a draw on move 31 immediately
taking the opportunity in the classical
game players are so sneaky they'll find
their way around the rules they'll find
those loopholes but we can forgive the
players for making those drawers if we
get treated to the spectacle of
Armageddon and we do see Wesley getting
ready to start his game against Anish
Gary should we do some predictions
before the the before the beginning of
this round absolutely I encourage it
what do you think nordeback against
faruga
I'm going to go white win
a draw and then but someone has to win
someone will walk away as a winner you
mean not in the classical just like that
not their Brooklyn not a background
sorry okay
I think far Asia might win it in the
Armageddon and there we see a very
relaxed Hikaru smiling with the white
pieces he actually is only one one
classical encounter against Magnus
Carlson do you think he can put it out
of the bag today
I have a feeling Armageddon and I'll say
that Armageddon will be a draw so Magnus
will take the points
or the share of the points
Judith
uh I put my bet on Hikaru in the playoff
he looks happy he looks composed Banker
I think
Magnus win in the classical game okay
and here we have Ari and tari playing
with the black pieces getting ready to
meet Fabiano caruana who has not yet
arrived Fabiano is one of those guys who
was quite punctual yeah he's quite
punctual I can reveal that I had a very
late lunch today and Fabiano was the
last one in the restaurant so maybe
doing some last minute preparation for
that game against Harry uh either way
I'm gonna say Carolina to take the
points tarry heartbreaking day yesterday
it's going to be tough to recover
he has to recover in classical game but
he's going to fail in the Armageddon
I think you're spot on Judith I'm
ganging up against you David
and there we see the former world
champion Magnus Carlsen getting ready
Fabiano has arrived at the board and
curiously enough hikaru's preparation
for today's game involved doing a talk
at the Norway Summit
yeah talking about his life as a
streamer talking about his
entrepreneurial kind of Endeavors there
talking about uh yeah how he's kind of
turned away from being a full-time
professional player and uh encompassed
all his business ideas there really
fascinating stuff but you wouldn't think
it's ideal preparation for such a big
match Judah do you think it will impact
him on the board as we see the first
move yeah for me it's really amazing to
follow Nakamura how he became a most
popular chess streamer we can say and at
the same time while sometimes calling
himself a chess amateur playing on the
highest level and he's number five in
the world I think right now and he was
very strongly not only playing in the
candidates tournament but it was just
clinch away that he would have been
playing the world championship match
right so this is a mystery for me how he
can do this yeah imagine just a draw
against dingleren last year in the final
round of the candidates and Nakamura
would have had a shot at the world title
but uh I wonder if he would be streaming
every day after the game if he would be
playing the world championship match but
why breaker winning formula right
because it seems like since he started
streaming he's relaxed he's super happy
and it just seems to be helping his
chest he's the only person I know that
can while streaming talk talk to chat
and also Play Good Moves I've tried it a
few times and it did not go well chess
wise
and uh there you see Hikaru taking back
back King's Pawn
what do you think he's going to play C4
D4 I would have guaranteed before the
game he would start with E4 and there we
go he takes it back and just teases chat
different tricks right to take it back
or to leave it there for seconds and
then to make your opponent trying to
guess that what is really going to
happen and move one
and Magnus of course he copies I'm going
to see Knight F3 Knight C6 and
maybe Magnus himself will play at Berlin
yeah we will await the opening Hikaru
usually goes for the Spanish uh when he
does double in one E4 I'm glad I must
say on behalf of Magnus that he's not
going for the French defense that back
of our head badly against Fabiano in the
first round and it wasn't a position
that he enjoyed getting out of the
opening there so this one it is the Roy
Lopez the Spanish and Moment of Truth
will Magnus go for the Berlin or his
world championship repertoire in
magnus's last classical game before this
tournament uh against myself he played
the Marshall Gambit and here we go no
Berlin today he kicks back the bishop
and we are headed towards the martial
Judith uh this is one of the openings
that's been your bread and butter as
well oh absolutely I even played it with
the black color in the later years of my
career but mainly I was playing on the
right side I'm very curious what Magnus
has in mind of course martial attack was
always a system which was bothering
people who are playing Rai Lopez and it
was always very challenging so that's
why many of the players already these
days they don't even enter into the
Marshall unless they want to make a draw
or want to be very solid and test the
memory of the other player of black
because you have to remember a lot of
things so if C3 then D5 that's the
Marshall but I'm expecting that it's
going to be avoided
it tends to be the pattern that people
avoid the Marshall because the martial
has pretty much been worked out quite
deeply
yeah I remember the days when I was
young and commentators would say yes
it's the Marshall it's the martial
attack we're going to see some
aggressive play now it's like oh no it's
the Marshall it's going to be a force
drawing 40 moves
times change that's how the opening what
people are playing it's transforming
right because players want to have a
game they want to be sharp and look at
that he's allowing them we have Marshall
on the board yeah actually if you ask me
to predict the opening beforehand I
would have said Nakamura is going to go
straight into this Nakamura doesn't
really want a slow maneuvering battle I
feel at least not in the classical
portion of this match and here we go
it's the Marshall is he going to grab
this Pawn as I did a few months ago
against Magnus Carlson and uh Knight
takes E5 on the board white will be a
pawn up but black will have activity and
a lead in development as compensation
but which means I think that it's uh the
strategy of Nakamura is to make it
Android practically and then go for the
uh Armageddon or at least play a no risk
position and in that game I mentioned
that I had against Magnus a few months
ago he played Bishop B7 against me and
he told me later it was his world
championship prep uh I think he told
many people so I'm not reviewing
anything
I was just wondering if you're not going
to get in trouble with this one in an
interview I believe so uh instead he
goes to C6 the main line the main move
and no surprises so far a well-known
position for me it's very interesting to
see this the strategy of Nakamura
because I think he's great in consuming
his energy
and basically he he was giving a talk
right in the just few hours before the
game of the start of the game and maybe
he didn't even have to spend too much
time right because he said okay I'm
going A4 Magnus is going to play E5 so
I'm going all the way to the Marshall if
he's going to play Berlin there is also
another way to simplify the position I'm
going to test him here and there Queen
F3 very common
so we'll go within a pawn or even the
phone compensation everything goes fine
and then I just go for the Armageddon
while Magnus had to prepare quite a bit
so it it has a
it's very practical
very pragmatic strategy he certainly is
and uh okay David neither David or
yourself Judy will be surprised to hear
that this has been played before 64
games in the other nice number 64. I can
say actually that I thought it was much
more okay can you guess how many games
end in a draw
64.
David
am I correct yeah if you play Bishop
takes Knight 64 of the games end in a
draw
I uh it uh yeah I had a bit of a cheat
code there I had studied this position
just a few months ago against Magnus and
I think I was ready to yeah take this
Knight off the board yeah Bishop D5 is
one of the the normal moves but I think
also Knight E2
also leads to some uh some Force draw
advance and rookie 8 94 Bishop G4
Queen G2 Queen H5 or something
some forcing lines here Judith yeah the
other one is Bishop D5 I think you also
try to simplify maybe with Bishop F4
afterwards but uh White is really trying
to get something extremely small just a
comfortable position you can't really
dream about real Advantage here but
basically you're testing the opponent
yeah that's the problem for white Jester
the fact that these three pieces are
asleep on the green side the fact that
it takes them two or three moves to get
into the game means that white cannot
Bank on an Advantage the extra Pawn for
white not too relevant right now it's uh
this extra D3 Pawn which often actually
just drops off the board a bit later you
have to be wary about your king as well
so all of those factors combined means
that white
lacks the well time for an objective
Advantage according to opening Theory
but Nakamura will try something the
martial attack white often has these
little small ideas to get a playable
position to get a small risk-free
Advantage it's just about whether Magnus
can neutralize that and 92 as you
mentioned Judith on the board yeah you
know I'm wondering sometimes that why a
player like Magnus why does he play
martial can you tell me uh why don't you
play I mean there is the and
there is there's so many different ideas
in the classical Ry Lopez and you can't
say that it's boring it's a very complex
game
so is he ready to go for equilish
position I understand the dynamic of the
position is very tempting because it has
a lot of energy but upon you get the
compensation
if you memorize all the lines it looks
pretty safe there are no huge dangers
right
yeah I think it's just the fact that uh
he's played too many world championship
matches he's a bit Jaded by that as
we've seen by him walking away out from
the world title and the more you study
with computers the more you realize the
Marshall is totally fine you equalize
with black and it gets the very best
players in the world that tends to be a
decent result and I've had this position
before myself as white we're about to
see an end game Nakamura has had it
against Magnus this exact position I
think uh in the past and it's a sign of
respect I think Judith uh Magnus
respects Hikaru enough to say I will
happily force a draw against you with
black and uh I think this one is going
to go down to the Armageddon Queens for
off the board the White Knight is pinned
in the center but white can use the fact
that there are some tactics uh along the
diagonal against the black king to
equalize this one I think we'll stay
with this one just a few more moves and
then we'll do a Roundup of the other
openings which are far more tense yes
and I have to say you're completely
right they have in fact played three
games and this particular variation but
uh well we have something a bit special
because we did in fact ask a very
important person about their
expectations of the Hikaru Magnus game
let's have a listen
it's a treat today I mean Magnus Carlson
Carl Nakamura is this the best matchup
we have in chess now yeah it's a big day
it feels like it might be a tournament
decider
um it's the first time they're meeting
in classical in four years I'm excited
I'm hoping lots of fans are tuning in
today because uh I have a feeling it's
going to be quite dramatic might be
dramatic on the board but who do you
think is going to win the confession
room oh
Nakamura was on fire yesterday I've got
to say like embracing his inner streamer
it was fun to watch we were cracking up
with laughter in the uh commentary room
um I don't know it depends on magnus's
mood I'm gonna say Naka just because
he's a bit more in the zone right now
with the streaming and who's going to
win on the board
oh I'll say Magnus with a drawn on again
thank you thanks
[Laughter]
very insightful comments there drama are
plenty would you would you say I mean
I've jinxed it first of all like the
first commentary uh accommodates his
curse there I'm everywhere you just uh
can't escape me sorry everyone at home
probably Sick Of My Voice by now but uh
yeah you heard it here first it's going
to be an Armageddon the place of raced
into the end game Judith well I had this
game I think exactly this position
against swedler in some event maybe
maybe World Championship behind the
Saint Louis 2005 or somewhere
but and they are going to repeat moves
and then in 20 minutes we have the first
Armageddon right
well what's
do you okay and they are literally
racing racing towards that draw I mean
we haven't we haven't even looked at any
other games and this these two will have
finished it's very interesting one they
only started 10 minutes ago
well what's your opinion on this type I
I mean how do you think about this
it's practical it makes sense for their
Tournament standings it makes sense uh
because they both deem each other as big
rivals for the title eventually we see
the handshake there uh of course
disappointing not to see kind of a
full-blooded fight against them but
that's the beauty of this format that's
why we love Norway chess we see an
Armageddon we get even more action
between these two so I don't think we
can complain too much and it's
understandable hikaru's had a long day
busy day giving a q a session earlier
and for Magnus with black good result
Sunny is a good result and of course
Hikaru did run a gauntlet you know he
started with two blacks in a row now
he's had his first White and agreed a
very quick draw against Magnus the
players will be back in roughly 20
minutes to face off in an Armageddon and
of course that will have a decisive
result someone will be walking away with
one and a half points the other one on
point and well
that short game let's have a look at the
bird's eye view and let's have a look at
the other games in progress because no
one else is doing
this very quick
three move repetition
yeah I hope we can't blame the players
too much it was all theoretical all been
seen before and it did and in that draw
and uh where to go next so it's still
early days in many of the games only
four or five moves and some of the
others but the game that's progressed
and developed the most is between Abdul
sotorov and alarisa ferrugia still all
the pieces on the board there all the
pawns on the board still very tense in
that battle and uh let's Maybe
do a bit of a Roundup uh just go around
the horn and check out all of the games
all of the opening stages
starting with that game
yeah it seems like
everybody developed
right and they are ready fortified the
two youngsters
yes and this is the current position
it's now move 11 all the pieces uh
remaining as mentioned Judith you
recognize the opening the structure I
guess
from the uh yeah the semi-sluff
uh the slav I'm not sure
semi slav I think yep and uh yeah it
feels like black is just saying to White
come on push in the center and why
they're saying no you start you push in
the center first and uh first I expect
both sides to bring their rest of their
pieces into the game maybe Abdus tour of
here just centralizes his Rooks what do
we think yeah and then that's the plan
right why it is building for the E4
break so he wait can play Rook D1 Rook
fd1 Rook 81 can even play a move that
I've toyed with Bishop D3 that was
recommended by Sam shankland in his
chess book course very subtle stuff
and lots of moves available you can even
actually take the time out to make
little moves like H3 and that's all
right it's just a very slow position
both sides
playing chess gonna make their
breakthrough
well these are the kind of positions
when we say the better wins right who
understands the position better who
understands the ideas better who
understands where the best places is for
your own on pieces yeah E4 is something
that white always wants to be playing
and sometimes white is postponing it
that well it's too early to simplify the
position right
and black wants to go E5 or sometimes C5
it's it's both our options if white
would be taking on D5 let's say there is
always a debate how you would be
capturing but most likely I guess people
take it with the e-pawn
and have the E8 Rook on a good
spot
though after C takes to D5 he takes D5 I
like very much for white The Outpost or
or the post of the night on F5 if it can
get there let's say one day every night
H4 Knight F5
uh in this position I think it's very
important for black that white cannot
play Knight E5 because if white could uh
reach out to E5 with the Knight and play
F4 that could be a huge Advantage
already
so everything the debate is going on in
the center on the E4 E5 Square
it's a bit of a waiting game right if uh
White now let's jump in maybe with some
moves uh if white does kind of gets
ambitious and play E4 then we see a
bunch of simplifications and after the
Black Knight hits the White Queen you
have a choice you can go ambitious maybe
slide across try and start a king side
attack but let's say white just kind of
steps back we'll see black breakout with
C5 at some point and this one unless you
have something immediate uh it feels
like black here is completely fine with
some very nice Bishops on these
diagonals so the question is do you wait
do you break out now and if we go back
to the live position just to show a few
more uh moves let me go back just for a
second because I want to show one idea
which I think can be important takes
takes takes Knight F6
goes back to C2 okay C5 and sometimes
it's important that The Rook is on E8
after DTX C5 Bishop C5 and if white
would be going Knight H Knight G5
because you would we may be trying to
pull out G6 and the weakness but if the
Rook would be on f8 H6 would be not
possible to Bishop F6 but now you just
play H6 and after Bishop F6 Queen takes
back and queen H7 you're smiling and
laughing you just go King f8 right and
nothing happens so this small details
count in these positions also Circle 8
it can be also useful this way yeah wow
I've never seen the subtlety of the kind
of I always see people play rookie 18
positions and I thought oh they're just
preparing E5 then it turns up as other
defensive reasons too it has other
benefits sometimes ah nice I'm learning
I'm taking notes and uh White is in the
meantime delaying this E4 push and
instead centralizing the Rooks and
alireza responding very quickly with
putting the queen on E7 and I've had
this position many times before and the
queen and the bishop they can also play
they can also line up to play Bishop A3
that's one idea that I've had a lot of
people do against me but at the same
time there's our ideas of black actually
first of all playing E5 breaking out
immediately or perhaps even taking on C4
and then playing E5 but uh I think the
most challenging lines are actually when
both sides just wait
as they are doing right now so it's a
very tense game
yeah I always struggle I must admit in
these types of positions it feels like
both armies are ready just staring
staring down at each other I never know
what to do next when to break out
Ivanka from your experience assuming
these two players have the same kind of
level of knowledge of this type of
position who do you think it's going to
favor stylistically
nordebec but uh but I don't know at time
um Let me let me just to wind my neck
back in
it is a very it is a very difficult
question because of course all the
action happens in the middle game and
the farouza will be very happy with his
position and I mean so many plans
available I mean if farooja wants to
liven things up you know you play for E5
if you just want to respond to whatever
white has in store then you just carry
on improving and I can see you can go H6
that's one move that I like to do
because I never knew whether I should be
going C5 or E5 and so H3 and I'm
expecting perhaps H6
yep just giving the black king some
space cutting out those uh those pesky
little Knight G5 jumps that you
mentioned unit in the other line H6
looks like a good copycat waiting move
it's the most frustrating thing and
Jesse opponent just copies you every
move and you don't know what to do next
yeah
I think that basically we were talking
in yesterday and day before there were
positions where we were talking about
the tension where whether you like for
example here c46 are you going to grab
on D5 or black is going to grab usually
you don't in these positions but there
are situations right when I capture he
captures how to do it
and and this is also attention now and
it's a matter of uh who is going to be
pushing E5 or E4 right because E4 is
something that you simplify so probably
you're not ready because black is
completely set up perfectly fine for
against it the only passive area of the
position is the Pawn on C6 which is
going to be playing C5 at the same time
if you think about black it's not so
easy for black to play E5 because then
white would take C takes D5 and then if
black takes back with the pawn then
there is going to be an isolated Pawn as
we've seen yesterday for example between
gokash and Nakamura isolated phone can
be travel also so it's kind of tricky so
both sound like should I play E4 or I'm
waiting for E5 and do I have a useful
move after H6 let's say because this
rookie one Rook d183 kind of moves it's
like it can be useful in a later stage
of the game but it's kind of waiting
moves right
my one of my first coaches would have
said it's a nothing move the lazy move
but uh sometimes those lazy moves are
effective that's practical harsh I think
I always call them luxury moves or
improving moves never lazy
and uh okay well this game looks like it
will be very tense and all the action
will be happening in a few moves as both
players get ready to mock their ground
but in the meantime
our reporters svara caught up with
Hikaru before the round started so let's
hear hikaru's thoughts
just gotta ask you for the position look
uh looked like white was doing well
white up a queen right yeah white has an
extra Queen so I think the kid's gonna
win and that's that's a good sign maybe
he'll be the next Magnus
uh Hikaru today it says fans all around
the world are anxiously awaiting this
matchup it's something special with
tikaranakamura against Magnus Carlson
but do you feel that as well I mean I've
played Magnus so many times probably
more times in the last three years
online than the previous 15 years that
we'd played each other so uh certainly
it's been quite a while since we played
classical game last time being 2019 so
looking forward to it and we'll see what
happens what do you expect from the
match today I don't know could be really
wild could be very boring uh it's your
guess is good as mine do you think we're
it's going to be one game or do you
think it's going to be a complete match
with an Armageddon I mean I don't know I
think it could be either way I think a
lot will depend on the opening and uh
I'll probably have something to say in
the confessional box so well you guys
will know my thoughts pretty early on we
look forward to that sure thanks
Karu
it's close to the chest it was boring in
the end but okay take a look at this the
head to head scores and very
interestingly enough Magnus completely
dominates the classical Hikaru actually
only having won one game in 2016.
and uh Magnus just winning the remainder
but when it comes to Rapids we can see
it's actually much closer
so basically he just made the
calculation right so the results himself
or he knows it exactly how it is and he
said okay I'm not going to be pushing it
if Magnus wants to play then he's not
playing Marshall right then go for some
triggering or some kind of closer
uh Ryan Lopez and then let's have a game
but he's not going to be pushing it so
it was it was clear from the interview
that he was ready to play but he was not
against on the short draw either yeah I
think just a great practical decision
the top players they are obsessed with
stats they do so much research uh Magnus
for example he's formerly number one in
fantasy football that shows the
attention to detail that players put
into their numbers into their records
against each other the head-to-heads and
all of that into your Hikaru knows
classical
historically is against him so why not
take his chance in the Armageddon he's
got white he backs himself three extra
minutes he's got a good score against
Magnus in recent times uh in class in
sorry in Rapid chess so yeah I think uh
it makes a lot of sense what he's doing
he seems in a good mood and I can't wait
for that one to start yes I I have to
say I detected a little Sparkle in his
eye when he goes could be boring yeah
I think he knew exactly what he wanted
like you guys mentioned and I I do think
I agree with you both it is a very
pragmatic decision you know play to your
strengths and clearly the two do have
like an online
rivalry as well as a blitz rivalry that
I mean Magnus and pikaru have been
fighting it out in those blitzwill
championships and yeah why not take your
chances but there is a big difference
though here Hikaru will be playing
Armageddon 10 minutes on the clock
has to win
yeah but it means also that they miss
out of the great scoring right because
if In classical game you win its you
score three points while in Armageddon
you well they secured one point in each
already but still the extra half a point
will go to the winner in Armageddon yeah
it's uh just a calculated risk here
they've basically both said okay the
leaders can extend their lead but we're
just putting points in the bank and the
one thing for sure is that he won't play
the same opening right Judith uh
hikari's gonna mix it up he will not
allow the martial attack again that's
for sure
so yeah he must have come prepared with
some ideas for the later Armageddon
sadly and we mustn't forget that they
did of course play each other in the
Norway Blitz and the opening day and do
you remember that crazy game where it
looked like Hikaru was winning was a
piece up and then Magnus kind of came in
with the king oh that was amazing yeah
it was one of the coolest game of the
blitz tournament that was amazing yeah
yeah that was topsy-turvy Magnus was
basically winning straight out of the
opening let it slip Hikaru was winning
then Magnus was winning and eventually
clinched it crazy stuff and uh yeah I
hope that one sets the tone for the uh
Furious speed that they will soon show
in the Armageddon and I mean while we
see the bird's eye view we'll come to
the other opening shortly but uh yeah
it's still early in this round as we
await Nakamura against Carlson
and uh let's uh let's have a look at the
bird's eye view and
okay
yeah lots of action shall we jump in
Ivanka what do we think uh we're kind of
torn into Minds here because we know the
Armageddon is soon to start between
Magnus and Hikaru they finished about 15
minutes ago already I will definitely
want to go to if we have the opportunity
to go to the mama jar of game later and
uh here we can see the Armageddon format
and black will win with a draw the
players keep the same colors white will
have 10 minutes black will have seven
minutes there will be a one second
increment after move 40 is not March but
it's a tiny little something and of
course important importantly one and a
half points fought a win and 1.4 a loss
and we also have a very special treat
for everyone because we have a very
special guest in the studio alongside us
and we have Marcus Village the CEO and
founder of Bolt so pleasure to have you
here in the studio
and I hear you're an avid chess fan
actually it's different
uh-huh and did you get your predict
prediction correct
were you a lot slightly annoyed that
they took it back and then they played
indeed but I mean that's how this goes
yeah and uh how did you start with chess
about your life these days more and more
sorry I started playing as a kid when my
parents as a lot of people do and then I
got more and more active in it over the
last year and a half I run a company and
that's always taking up most of the time
but chess is a really great way to get
your mind off that and then focus on
something completely different yeah I
had a chess capture your imagination
because you said you kind of got into it
in the last year and a half yeah it's uh
actually something I see is a great way
to Again release some stress focus on
completely something different I've
always been a lot into board games and
just obviously is the most famous and
the best of them all so it was natural
I'm eventually going to come back to
this one very good and you set out to
solve a big problem when you created
your company bolt which is all about
Mobility Services in talent and do you
see parallels between the Strategic and
problem solving thinking applied there
and chess absolutely I think that
especially games like this where you
need to think both tactically and then
strategically something that you can
apply to many other parts of life as
well and it's very clear from some of
the famous chess players as well who've
been able to translate those skills into
other fields of Life yeah and uh does
running ball feel like a chess game at
times indeed that's sometimes absolutely
these I mean you have a very heavy
competition going on between a lot of
different companies and obviously we try
to put our best food forward and then
serve our customers the best and you
need to plan really many many steps
ahead so it's not something that of
course you can just uh you know you need
to decide it in a few minutes you
usually have a bit more time but
obviously you're under time pressure as
well mm-hmm and you're the youngest
founder of a billion dollar company in
Europe and you're not even 30. would you
ever think of retiring and becoming a
chess professional unfortunately I think
it's probably too late for that unless
I'm gonna dedicate my entire next couple
of decades into this but no I think
you're just gonna start early I started
the company when I was 19. it's already
now a decade in so it's actually quite a
while and the lesson from this is that
great things don't always happen
overnight but you kind of put in years
and years of dedication yeah and would
you as a CEO consider excellence in
chess an important asset for a candidate
applying for your company well if some
Grand Masters apply to work at bolt I
would absolutely uh yeah put them on top
of the list and then consider them very
highly
you guys have some job opportunities I
need a new job after this
and I'm kind of curious um what is your
pet who is your personal favorite in
this event to win
oh it's a very tough question with all
the great players here
um I must say I'm still rooting for for
Magnus this time
so I I hope who's gonna win yeah and uh
what kind of chest style do you have
um I'm still very much a novice so I'd
say I'm more more aggressive I once in a
while I enjoy the sacrifice for some
positional gains okay so you go right
for the attack from the beginning
whenever possible so as early as I can
as early as you can
and is that how you approach life I
think very much so I mean
entrepreneurship as well I mean it's
it's not something that you can play
very defensively only I mean you gotta
seize the opportunities go on the
offense and that very much is true in
both business Sanchez and I have to ask
you but you might you can whisper your
answer
whose style do you like the most in
terms of Chess out of our players
very tough question
um but but still I think probably Magnus
Carlson is the one that I uh I think
everybody's looking up to at least over
the last decade so I'm gonna go with
that as well yeah and finally what is
your favorite piece
favorite piece
um I'd say it's the it's still the queen
uh just again the most versatile one so
it's a common answer
going into Armageddon and you've said
you you're a big fan of Magnus Carlson
and of course hikara Nakamura and I'd
like to thank you so much Marcus for
coming into the studio and for your time
thank you
wow and uh Magnus has brought us really
good luck here in the studio because
it's the king's Gambit wow a romantic
opening you nearly never see this in the
21st century and Judith your eyes have
lit up absolutely because this was my
opening when I was a baby I was still
starting out with this opening with 2f4
sacrificing the King Pawn there
and I was playing with Bishop C4 not
with this very aggressive from the 18th
century we can say Knight F7 no not yet
oh you want to keep our pieces Leo that
black king out into the open but this is
a older variation as you mentioned and
yeah it has a decent reputation of solid
reputation for black I'm surprised
Magnus has given back the pawn No More
Kings Gambit uh it is level material in
Hikaru looking away to the left there
that signifies he's trying to remember
something uh he normally has that face
on when he's recalling opening Theory
I've had this position myself against
the likes of Nigel short and uh okay
what will Hikaru play I'm surprised he's
gone in for this because Magnus had that
world championship match against jando
pomonishi in 2021 who had just released
a chess uh a chessable course on the
king's Gambit so Magnus will have
studied this in recent times but uh
novelty incoming I mean hikaru's little
poor move never been played before
okay
like the most impressive move I've got
to say Judith nope not making chances
for white now there's kind of some
transposition and two games in the
database what do you think it looks very
good for black because black is much
more developed right now look at White's
pieces none of them developed yet
and uh but it's it's really cool that we
have a king's Gambit in in an Armageddon
I played it last time you know in 2010
or something at some point I was playing
a rapid event in Mexico and I played
against Apollo and I won very
convincingly I couldn't believe it
myself it's like a nice exchange
sacrifice or something on that was it or
some kind of sacrifice on F4 in that
game maybe I remember watching it and
thinking wow this is uh I'll just should
be played yeah that was shocking that I
don't even know why I came up with that
idea to play king's Gambit but but here
really white is in trouble from
development point of view right I mean
Knight is going to jump to E5 or D4 in a
second and you can't stop both
yeah you can't stop both once the Knight
arrives on E5 or D4 maybe the bishop
will come out
black will be very quick to Castle
queenside
doesn't look like the king's Gambit has
worked out this time it has backfired
this is unfortunately why it doesn't
make an appearance more often at the top
level
well King's Gambit is something that is
great if you your opponent frightens
from you you know got afraid but Magnus
is not that type of guy he is going to
be smiling at your F4 right
yeah he's normally the one who puts in
all the hard work to surprise the
opponent Magnus and he's got uh given a
position that he probably knows very
well very quickly from him so far but we
have seen two successful games in the
Armageddon where the players have just
played some wild position and they've
sacrificed material and they're saying
you know black simply doesn't have
enough time to handle all those
complications even though let's face it
it probably is a great position for
black so the games I'm thinking of is
like Shakura against Ariane he just gave
a pawn has some initiative yes but
that's a different story and yesterday
let's not forget that uh Escape
trick but uh Magnus pulled on her Wesley
when he sacrificed the whole Rook yeah
but those were already middle game stuff
right and from Mama jarov he just wanted
to go into full complications the
problem is for white here that he just
has no time to develop properly because
you I mean what can you do I mean it's
it's at First Sight it's really
miserable so Knight C3 let's say or okay
he went to Queen F2 kind of
prophylactical move black I think will
go Knight E5 trying to jump to G4 but
another idea is just to develop with the
C8 bishop and even costs along so the
the only problem for black is that there
are so many tempting options I think G3
is something that maybe
the plan can be for for white that's why
Magnus played Rook G this Rook G8 is a
different group G8 then after something
yesterday where's the story this one we
can understand Rook on an open file but
yesterday a bit more mysterious and uh
okay Hikaru is threatening to jump into
the center with the white knight this
was cut out by Magnus Carlsen uh Bishop
B6 really nice move and both sides need
to rush to Castle it feels like uh
surely Bishop D2 is going to happen and
White's King needs to run to safety
before it's too late I want to give
credit to Hikaru they're just uh I'm so
glad he promised entertainment maybe
this is why in the interview he was
smiling he knew what he was going to do
in the Armageddon he knew that he had a
surprise obviously if it might have
backfired so far but still early days
yeah maybe I'm not fair that uh that I I
said so many bad things about White's
position maybe it's not as bad as as it
looked two moves ago
I just don't see how you can be better
that's the problem and you're in a
must-win situation but
but I think your car is just being
practical he's saying you know I don't
care about being better because the
tussles will be happening in the later
stages of the game and if Hikaru is a
bit more familiar with those positions
then you know he can handle them with
great resourcefulness
I like the queen on a F2 actually
because it's it it ties down the C6
Knight and attacks the A7 phone so at
some point Knight D5 can be good or even
Knight B5 the other idea is to go Bishop
E2 and then Rook F1 and attack the F4
Pawn so black should know what he's
doing
and look at magnus's last move trademark
Magnus
gonna go into an end game yeah and uh
not just wanting the Queen's off for
safety but I think it's directly
correlated to Judith's point the White
Queen was actually White's best piece
potentially on F2 and uh White had some
counter-attacking ideas there so
bullying the White Queen back if it
wasn't a must-win situation maybe hit
car root would have allowed that trade
instead he's been forced to retreat and
suddenly the white piece is back it's
Fisher random but we know he's uh Fisher
underwear Champion Hikaru loads of the
white pieces now on the back rank what
can black do to up the pressure to
maintain the momentum if white does get
two or three moves he should be okay
watch out for 92 as well hitting the
black queen hitting the pawn on F4 and
okay preemptively again prophylaxis uh
just dropping back with the black queen
maybe getting ready to plant the Knight
on the dominant D4 Square yeah you kind
of feel that White's best move is
actually to put the queen back on F2 but
of course Hikaru is in a must win
situation cannot do that and the thing
that is concerning about White's
position
how on Earth is he going to develop the
light squared bishop and The Rook
well this is the reason I like the queen
D4 very much what Magnus played in the
previous move because it's not only that
he pushed away the very well placed F2
Queen because it was an attacker but
also it defended the G2 Pawn so right
now Bishop E2 is not exactly possible
because the pawn is hanging on G2
okay and a move from Hikaru he does
retreat Knight E2 and that move is given
a question mark by the All-Seeing engine
what could uh why could that be a
mistake it feels like you can get greedy
and grab one right
I mean hello
[Laughter]
Fisher rest taking on H2 in that world
championship match Fisher he doesn't go
for it Magnus more practical decision
just playing F5 and okay the cross there
means maybe a miss a missed opportunity
for Magnus was that just capturing this
pawn it took courage
instead a safer decision from the former
world champion and G3 Hikaru fighting
back now utilizing this pin the F4 Pawn
cannot be touched you cannot take on G3
maybe you can but uh either way you have
to calculate well here yeah and it does
feel that Magnus is losing a little of
the control he had with this especially
with this last move by Hikaru G3 great
move
and we should mention the clock time
three and a half minutes now for Magnus
fauna four minutes uh 50 almost for
Hikaru Nakamura I've seen these two face
off in title Tuesday multiple times
where there's a one second increment
Magnus has lost on time
countless times in their encounters he
always seems to flag against Hikaru so
he's going to get nervous if the clocks
ticked down meanwhile F takes E4 Judith
which one is Hikaru going to recapture I
think G3 was something that Magnus was
not expecting and this is why I also
thought after Knight D2 is little attack
on their fourth one I want to go Bishop
C3 but actually G3 was the idea GF is
very logical
I think black
right yeah it feels strange to allow
this move with Tempo lining up against
the black king on the diagonal hitting
the black queen maybe he's just gonna
drop back maybe he'll just move his
Queen away and say trade-off Bishops
please uh Bishop H3 maybe he'll just
Retreat and there is another question
what about Knight G3 I know and I was
thinking you could back that up with
moves like F5 but okay that requires a
lot of calculation
yeah there's multiple ways to hit this
black queen and Magnus better have some
answers off his sleeve but Hikaru has
slowed down it's really tense it feels
like the critical moments could be
around now exactly I also wanted just to
point out that he spends this few
seconds or maybe even a little more
Knight G3 or Bishop H3 Knight G3 played
on the board The Black Queen has to move
the question is where does she
centralize or question mark attached to
that move as well maybe a mistake giving
black an opportunity
maybe all I can grab on G3 or what can
be the problem
I'm thinking about going for that A2
Pawn that you've both been mentioning a
few times okay the black queen just
steps back well going for the A2 Pawn
Yeah I wanted to go for it with the
black queen and it's important now that
Queen E4 is not possible because Bishop
D5 would win The Exchange
both players under three minutes well
Hikaru just over and uh we see a trade
of Bishops F5 look at that wow tactics
Galore yeah black cannot take yeah it's
not F5 and Bishop H3
but maybe it's about time to take on A2
no he wants to take with the queen
big threat on the board Queen takes A2
might be devastating and in a
checkmating attack but you can simply
play some safety chess and move the king
to protect that pawn and he does do that
and now Magnus centralizing the Knight
and again it just feels like any
anyone's game although big threat on the
board of night coming into F3 and so we
we see the same pattern keep repeating
time and time again you know now the
White Queen attacks the pawn on A7 yeah
two can play at that game he attacks the
pawn and Magnus ignores it completely
wow nerves of Steel he's arguing that
Queen takes Pawn is not as dangerous as
it looks because uh later on the black
Bishop will move and vacate a square for
the black king on D7
wow okay it feels like he needs to
gamble it's a bit like magnus's game
yesterday in the Armageddon against
Wesley Queen takes A7 happened there too
and it worked out well for white but
somehow this is not that position
when magnus's Queen was on A7 things
started to become much better than
before and here the The White Square
Bishop will be incredibly strong of
Magnus
and now we can see that the pieces the
pawns are not really good of white there
are a lot of weaknesses yeah Black's
King is safe it's got extra protection
around an extra shelter compared to the
white king and like you say Judith this
is not something that you get away
against Magnus
nothing classical at least but this is
Armageddon two minutes now for white
Hikaru is down on the clock not good
news for uh the American fans there
what to play It's hard there's tactics
all over the place you're threatening to
take this Pawn undermine the White
Knight on e4 also Knight C4 is a threat
both I mean isn't it time to mobilize
the rook and he does do that and maybe
there are some ideas of Rook takes
Bishop in the air I can see the
evaluation but hating White's position
but still when the players have less
than two and a half minutes on the clock
it's going to get tense
wow and we did see that uh there was a
missed opportunity for Magnus we saw the
Red Cross appear with his last move but
he plays a very safe one can't blame him
for that there are going to be tactical
opportunities later
he's up on time with the great position
as said there in the feature chat Magnus
Carlson right now Kara needs some magic
he's allowed Bishop takes porn
he's done it willingly maybe that was uh
the lesser of the evils there
Smash and grab that what uh that white
porn on A2 has disappeared but white has
gained some time in return going on the
attack now counter-attack
hitting the black queen or Magnus is
zooming In For the Kill Judith
um he's not joking here
no big threat on the board of Queen A5
check and something is going to happen
on A2
something's gonna happen the queen and
Bishop combo there for black looking
really menacing you need to block
somehow with the White Queen with the
white Rooks
but it feels like it's hanging by a
thread under one minute now for Hikaru
maybe he'll play some B4 or something
just to protect this A2 square but it's
kind of hopeless yeah Magnus with a
better position and also more time on
the clock and the players are on move 31
which means that still some moves left
before they get that one second
increment and as we see a set of Rooks
leave the board
yeah Magnus is pulling up and with the
ongoing initiative so that trade seems
to help black in A4 seems to be quite
quite a strong move in H2 and queen H4
so kind of a double attack yeah that
looks like a killer no but uh Magnus
decides to weave a mating net Bishop
comes down to B3 big threat of Queen A4
on the board
almost Unstoppable threat Unstoppable if
you have 30 seconds at least how does
white get his pieces in the White Knight
the white Bishop there just offside
unable to come back to the rescue of
their King
as I said in the future chat there
Hikaru does need a miracle with 30
seconds left queen A4
goes away still some
the fighting spirit is there yes yeah
but Hikaru 23 seconds and uh check uh oh
the white Rook is going to drop the
white Rook is undefended Magnus wins it
but his Knight Falls Hikaru is still
fighting
still in the game for now at least I'm
not even sure that Nakamura did not give
it on purpose with Bishop G4 yeah I
think he had to he had to give something
up but Magnus playing for tricks now
Bishop takes porn really nasty if the
bishop was captured there black had
Queen F4 check picking up one of White's
pieces and now everything's coming
through surely Judith this is going to
be Checkmate if it's not going to be
Checkmate I think he Magnus will be
winning hikaru's Queen at the end of it
on time yep and we see a handshake
Magnus takes the Armageddon Victory with
the black pieces and Nets one and a half
points well Hikaru did promise US
fireworks and in the end the Armageddon
game did deliver that was super exciting
yeah well played by both players Hikaru
choosing the king's Gambit bringing
romance back to chess but in the end
Magnus just unflusted too strong
absolutely it was uh it was a good try
but it happens when uh it does the
opening doesn't turn out to be
reasonable because he started out from a
first position right after move 10 it
was uh very clear then he somehow came
back and it was kind of balanced but he
knew exactly that he has to fight for a
win even a draw would not save
himself because uh because the point
will be on last night I did feel that
hikaru's opening Choice meant that he
had to use the time to navigate those
opening complications and in the end
that kind of costume went he really
needed that time to figure things out
this is why the opening is actually very
important not only in the classical game
but also in the Armageddon game it is
you really have to have you you need
your strategy well thought out and uh
and then of course play out the game so
the opening is only the first part but
if things are going wrong then you can
be in big trouble yes and uh well that
was a early excitement and I think it's
time for us to take a quick breather as
we are gonna take a break so see you in
a few minutes
foreign
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
and compete by voting for your predicted
results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and we are back in action and a chess
excitement is continuing as we have a
very special guest in the studio with us
we have none other than Magnus Carlson
and Magnus how are you feeling after
that short but exciting encounter
yeah I'm feeling uh feeling all right
um
sort of a hard harder suspicion that in
case I wanted to be
solid today he probably wasn't going to
appreciate it considering the fact that
he had uh he'd had a good start
um
and then yeah obviously
it's good to win the the Armageddon not
the realest so
I'll show in the first game and then did
you expect the king's Gambit no I didn't
really expect anything for the second
second game but like
if you gave me
a list of like Alternatives sorry or a
list of ways that the first game would
finish like the very way it finished
would probably be a top top of top of
the list I mean
um I thought there was
probably more than well considerably
more than 50 chance that he was just
gonna
but he was just gonna drop everything
everything off and uh you know um
with the way I played I sort of sort of
accepted accepted that if if I'd spin
like if I'd been desperate for for a
fight I obviously would have chosen
something um something different but um
I don't think you've ever expect the
king's Gambit but uh it was not an
unpleasant surprise let's say
so you're happy when your opponents are
trying to surprise you with the king's
Gambit yeah
um well there are other ways to uh
there are other ways to play there are
there are more well other ways to
surprise there are Less Pleasant for uh
for sure the thing is
also the king's gamut is not is not that
bad like with good preparation you can
make it at least semi-playable for for
white uh but the thing is black has so
many good ways to
uh to play and it's not particularly
difficult to to play for the black
pieces so I think that's the main
main issue for for uh for white there
well basically after move 10 when your
pieces were already out Knight C6 Queen
F6 Rook G8 Bishop H6 it showed that well
probably you had a clear Advantage
already right
yeah I mean back in the day I mean I
played this uh I have fond memories of
this line I played it against uh
Grandmaster uh fedorov from uh Belarus
with the black actually that was the
game that I secured my last Grandma's
Norm so that that that's probably the
last time I had this line and in that
line that game we played some long
forests uh Force line which ended up in
a fairly equal position like I was
slightly better but I had no reason to
not to accept his his girlfriend in that
game but but yeah I think the way he
played was
um it was not unreasonable I just think
yeah it's just very easy for for black
to play you have good activity all your
pieces are on aren't good squares and
and you have you have a few Pawn breaks
as well man you get such a position in
move 10 and you're playing with the
black pieces and draw is enough do you
want to win or you play for a draw or
just your your hand moves and makes good
moves whatever happens yeah the it's an
interesting uh interesting dilemma there
um
I think I was kind of stuck a little bit
in between uh when I was trying to play
a little bit solid and then uh at some
point I I just I missed a couple of his
his moves and it wasn't so so easy so I
think I lost my my advantage but
fortunately it never got out of out of
hand and even if it like
to play a little bit better there I
wasn't particularly particularly worried
and what do you feel about this
Armageddon format no I think it's very
good like
um imagine if this game had happened and
there hadn't been an army kid and like
it would still have
been
you know it's still it's not still not
ideal but at least you get something out
of it both as a player and as a specter
so I think it's yeah I think it's really
good oh it adds some obviously it adds
some
stress on the players but I think we
should be able to to handle that how
much are you preparing for the
Armageddon itself when you come to a
match because you know that if it's a
draw then you have to be ready to to
play the Armageddon do you play for both
do you prepare for both games or only
for the classical and then you say that
okay I will have 20 minutes to figure
that out yeah it depends um the first
two games today I basically just thought
I'll play or I'm sorry the first two
armageddons in this tournament I
basically thought play the same opening
and what happens happens
um in other years yeah I have prepared
different stuff for for Armageddon uh at
times especially with with white if
you're not too happy with the way the
first game has gone or maybe you'd
played some some idea and then you know
you can't really use it again because
they have 20 minutes to check yeah but
it depends on the situation which color
do you prefer white or black the
Armageddon I prefer the color that I
play
and uh
tougher opening blades and a tough start
I mean how do you feel about that yeah
um
it's it's not so good of course like I'm
on I'm on minus minus one at least I've
won my Armageddon so that helps a little
bit but it's um yeah it's obviously far
from Ideo uh but at least I feel like a
lot better physically than I did the
first
um first couple of days so that's that's
something something positive
um so I've given myself especially if
Fabi wins now I've given him quite a big
uh Head Start but um
I think
um I've definitely played three of my
very most solid opponents so I'm sure
there will be will be chances
um
and I'll you know I'll do my best to
just try and stay focused and take them
and do you have a pre-tournament routine
a pregame routine rather uh yeah
try and eat a bit go for a walk relax
not too much
Morrow is going to be a free day so are
you going to be the classical
preparation of yours doing some sports
with the other players of participants
or you have any special other plans for
recharging no actually I I mean I
generally love to do some sports
um I'm not sure there will be will be
time but yeah I'm up for for anything
because it's normally a football game
isn't there or is that there has been in
the there has been in the past
um yeah but it definitely helped me now
in Poland I played plays in football and
um
day before the last day and I felt
really energized um for for the game so
yeah that would be good what position do
you play on the football pitch depends
um
if I play like the chess tournament I
I'm usually just loafing around and
trying to score a couple goals
[Laughter]
yeah can I just say something about I I
find it very interesting uh
strategically what's happening in the of
the sator of uh firozia game um
so
um
well first of all it's a little bit
unusual uh for black to to allow this
structure I think especially with the
with the Bishops
um
with the the bishop Bishops exchanged
but it's very typical alireza that he he
wants to keep
some uh some more imbalance in the
position but another break's last move
is very interesting Rook B1 because I
think the point is to force to move A5
um otherwise for instance if the queen
moves back B4 would be strategically
desirable for for white so I think he
potentially is going to spend
at least one Temple trying to force A5
just to to weaken the um
uh the B5 square and potentially the B6
Pawn as well so I find that uh quite
quite interesting but generally speaking
white is a little bit
uh which is a little bit better
um maybe he's also going to go for Queen
B2 and then pushing B4 after
um
what about Knight E4 with black now yeah
94 I assume he takes Knight D2
um You probably have to go back then
um with the with the queen yeah
and uh then you can push B4 as white and
I think white is strategically a little
bit better
so um probably
yeah uh but I think otherwise is often
is not so unhappy with these situations
where he's where he's a little bit worse
he um
um he usually finds a way to complicate
things and then
it's anyone's game
and and uh do any other games catch your
eye
yeah I think Fabio has a pretty good
position
um
I think
I think aryan's decision to
um
to Castle was a little bit
it was a little bit dubious probably
um and now I think white is white is
definitely definitely better I actually
played
I actually played it a couple of times
myself the position before castling
um
uh the the point is that iron ones are
in by casting who wanted to prevent an
early Bishop H6 but it seems to me
that's probably the Curious is worse
than the
than the disease and here I think he's
just um
he's just worse with without a lot of
counterplay
deceptive isn't it because it does look
like the king is safe as houses there
and yeah but now now that black has
played C5 then why it has strategic
potential against
the D5 Pawn as well so uh Fabi is
probably gonna switch modes you know he
he's probably gonna go G3 king of one
King G2 at some point or he may even
switch completely on this castle and as
we know having the pawn on H5 is never a
bad thing
that is true that's one thing I've
learned in the last few years that uh H5
is good at the despite what I was told
in my earlier chess teachings
so our iron may go for C4 and then
just try and try and Advance on the on
the on the queen side just to have some
counter play but isn't the must to play
C4 otherwise it seems like the D5 will
be in trouble
yeah probably
um I mean I I guess you could move play
some move like Rook c8s or something but
you never really want to take on D4
probably either so
so
um yeah probably that's just 20 what
what he's got to do just
really hope that it doesn't get um get
mated
um I I mean I know
that Fabian such position sometimes can
get a bit apprehensive uh as well when
he he doesn't see a clear way and um and
and the opponents certainly get against
counter play so
from at least from
from a psychological point of view I
think it would not be a bad choice
game
yeah
depends on the XP moves really like I
think long-term black should be fine
Quincy seven Bishop D7 or some sort of
E5
um maybe black can start with E5 and
Knight B3 Queen C7 also
yeah I mean I don't think black is
remotely worse there
um
here yeah what is what is the move there
like maybe watch could start going for
some strange ideas like Queen D2 and
then either Queen C3 or queen A5
doesn't look doesn't look like position
looks very good
yeah I agree uh yeah no problems whatso
whatsoever and then
uh so give me it's just a dead raw so
yeah
so you'll see uh Wesley play another
Armageddon then what were your thoughts
on yesterday's Armageddon because you
went quite gung-ho at the end yeah but I
mean I I realized pretty early in the
opening that I I just messed up the move
order pretty badly and then I was just
lost so I had to attack
yeah it was not out of
yeah I was just out of pure necessity
um
but it wasn't it wasn't as bad as it
looked I have to say no that's that
that's true uh but you don't really
spend a lot of time thinking about that
it's just when I went for Queen A4 I
just thought yeah otherwise I'm just
lost so let's go
it was a good choice in the end and yeah
well thank you very much Magnus for
joining us here in the studio and good
luck in the rest of the tournament thank
you good luck thanks
and uh there we can see
and there we can see gukesh deep in
thought against chakra mamajarov but uh
that was incredible to hear magnus's
thoughts both on the games and of course
how he doesn't fear the king's Gambit at
all
which I think will come as a cold shower
because the king's Gambit has a cult
following I have to say
yeah it's a favorite of many Club
players many players starting out their
chess Journey or Magnus Heartbreaker
he's killing romantic chess but it's
nice to see him so relaxed and so
confused it yeah absolutely it was nice
to see him that he was happy to share
his thoughts also about other games
and uh yeah I think he's realistic very
much where he's standing in the
tournament right now and he's hoping to
to recharge himself and and somehow to
get in in the mood to fight out the next
games and I'm sure we will see some
great stuff yeah I I
decided to I mean I mean he seemed in a
good mood like you said you know he
seemed relaxed and the fact that he
could laugh about yesterday's game
against Wesley where he just went yeah
you know what hold my hands up in the
air I was completely lost messed up and
I find it quite refreshing at that there
is so much honesty from our top players
that there's not so much ego like no no
no no I was completely winning
and uh well I I guess maybe that's the
influence of computers or maybe that
kind of influence of the streaming and
social media that the players are much
more accessible
I think it's uh you're right on that uh
idea that the engines are are making the
players
and more open about the truth and
sharing it because practically the the
amateurs were watching with engine they
know it first before the players right
what is the the real truth of the
position but it was interesting that
yeah he admitted well okay he was lost
it was not that bad maybe in his hands
if he would be playing on the other side
with black yeah that's how he would feel
well it was bad enough but I think it's
very important to to stay realistic and
be critical about yourself still having
your self-confidence that okay you're
good but okay you make mistakes and
actually yesterday indeed he had a
really bad position
yeah and my theory is that he is so
popular because he is relatable he's one
of the first Champions as you mentioned
Ivanka who's ever kind of admitted that
human side that he blunders that he
makes mistakes I don't think you would
have seen it from any of his
predecessors I'm not sure Gary Kasparov
would have ever admitted that he was
lost even in a position like that one
yeah but uh yeah refreshing honesty from
Magnus there and uh okay well let's have
a look at some of the games
um which ones take your fancy we we had
some very interesting insights from
Magnus Carlson the one that I'm curious
about is the game Fabiano against Aryan
Fabiano of course on form but uh it was
interesting that both you and Judith and
Magnus all said oh Ariana's in trouble
yeah let's jump into that game uh Ivanka
Fabi uh as Magnus said could extend uh
his lead at the top of the table uh he's
had a great start to the event and with
the white pieces against the underdog
Ariane he will be all guns blazing he
will want to strike and yeah I don't
know what it was uh Judah I completely
agree with Magnus just Instinct wise I
thought oh this is so ugly for black I
think just strategically it's just what
is black hoping for it's like if you
ever trade off these Pawns in any
scenario black is left with that isolani
the isolated Pawn on D5 where I'm having
nightmares flashbacks to yesterday's
game where kakesh got beaten in the end
with the isolated Pawn Yeah there might
be some kind of air around the black
king even if it goes to an end game
sometimes they'll be back rank uh kind
of mating ideas if the Queens remain on
the board with the white Pawn on H6 I
think maybe just uh kind of from
experience as well this type of
structure for black it's really shaky uh
Magnus mentioned the D5 Pawn as well
watch out for that one to be weak can we
go to that critical moment that that
Magnus and yourselves have highlighted
when Aryan castled too early because I
think that's quite an instructive point
because if you were to look at the
position you would think that castling
is actually the most natural thing in
the world yeah let's go back there
actually let's just do a quick recap
from the start uh because we were very
much focused on the Nakamura versus
Carson matchup so it was a Queen's
Gambit declined by transposition and uh
here the capture on D5 signaling the
Carlsbad structure white developed Queen
C2 and now black played the move G6 just
supporting the uh Bishop F5 move that we
will shortly see this bishop often the
problem child for Black's position and
uh he went for this trade and it was
here after the trade of Bishops that I
guess Magnus was saying played the
useful moves first maybe develop this
Knight first uh maybe do some other
stuff wait for white to show his hand if
white cast was kingside then it's far
safer for black to copy uh in the near
future Magnus mentioned maybe aryam was
scared in this position Knight D7 a move
like Bishop H6 but this doesn't look
like it's too scary uh you can kind of
kick it back with the move Knight G4 you
can even play a move like Bishop f8 in
these positions and this is a very safe
haven for the black king So castling did
invite white to take take and play H4
thoughts on that student
well it seems like a very tempting
option for white I would be also someone
to go for this age for kind of idea it's
you you reach out to H5 with your
opponent because black probably does not
want to go H5
though I don't know after H5 would it be
the long castle and Rook G1 G4 or
something like that probably that would
be the unpleasant surprise for black
totally but I have a confession to make
no because of course Norway chess has a
confessional I've actually castled many
a time with the black pieces so then
when you guys said oh mistake I was like
oh my goodness me I had a in my
Armor All Along
I didn't know this I just thought of
natural yeah I didn't know either uh to
be honest it looks very natural to
Castle as black but when your opponent's
king is flexible here I guess uh you
just give your opponent more options we
often see players delay castling when
the center is blocked these days uh in
the Carlsbad in all sorts of uh openings
if the sense is blocked they just keep
their options open because due to the
influence of alpha zero they have
realized that H4 in any position tends
to be slightly more scary than we
previously thought also black does lack
Pawn breaks black has the bishop versus
the kind of pair of knights here so
black needs to open the position up but
the only way to do that is what Ariane
did and as well Magnus mentioned the
drawbacks the D5 porn extremely weak so
okay current position Judah is this one
Knight B4 on the board
well the question is where the queen is
going to be moving back right because
for example if you go to D2 probably
that is not the best move because black
can take on D4 and it's not going to be
an isolated Pawn because after Knight D4
Bishop different the queen cannot take
back because of Knight C to check
so which means that Queen D2 would be
something that does not look so good to
me so probably if we go back it's either
Queen B1 or queen C Queen E2
those are the alternatives for white I
don't think when B5 would be something
good I think then also C takes D4 or
that that's what I'm thinking at first
so Queen B1 let's say but uh
yeah somehow CD4 seems to be
though it's still possible Knight D4 and
Bishop D4 Queen B4 it's also something
to consider it's interesting like
because for me it would be a choice
between Queen B1 and queen E2
like what draws you to Queen B1
well the the question is for me how
black is going to be continuing whatever
move I go so let's say queen B1 if can
black go C4 and then uh optionally have
the Knight on D3 but it's more important
I think for black to play what the
Magnus was talking about to somehow to
push the pawns on the Queen's side
somehow I don't know Queen D7 B5 or Rook
B8 B5 A5 going back with the Knight and
then pushing B4 but you may as well be a
little bit worried that it can be very
slow because once the one white knight
can transfer from C3 to E2 and F4
white king probably locates on E2 or G3
King F1 King G2 it's even more safe and
then you have to keep it in mind that it
can be anytime that you open up the H
file which can be very annoying for
black even though the F6 Bishop is is
defending quite well the the problematic
squares for the king like the h8 square
but it can be something that in every
single muftari has to be calculating
again in the game whether is H takes G6
now more unpleasant than before
should we have a bet which way he's
going to go with the queen in this
position it's really tough to call I
mean I don't know what my instinct says
to be honest my instinct is calculate
this one first queen B5 if it doesn't
work then I look for backups uh I agree
we need to
but you know what after Queen B5 maybe
A6 and look what a trap Queen C5 he
should be seven oh you got me whoops
trapped in the middle of the board so
okay definitely not Queen B5 okay yeah
somehow I had the feeling that it's uh
you have to calculate it because that's
the most inviting one but at the same
time it's still very tricky I would go
Queen B1 to leave this space for my
knight on A2
and how would you meet this move we're
just ignoring the Knight on D3 if it
arrives I guess I'll probably can give
one G3
let's say I plant it in
I guess you can always remove it if you
need to
with Knight to E1
a difficult position to assess difficult
because the queen in the other hand
Queen on E2 can be more useful because
in such a position after Knight D1 Queen
F3 would be yeah already prepared to
attack the D5 Pawn right but then on the
other hand we need to on the board a
queen E2 on the board yeah I was just
like on the other hand the queen on B1
kind of like ties up those loose ends on
the queen side
yeah so the difference might be in that
type of position just to show
um yeah the White Queen coming out via
this angle F3 or G4 and uh yeah from F3
it would stare down at the D5 Pawn I
think this is a great decision
um it's always hard to kind of choose
instinctively two or three options
sometimes but that's where we were had
to calculate didn't we just to kind of
come to the reconclusion and likely the
same thoughts were going through
fabiana's head in that long think that
he just had
well it's a big question I think now
that how to decide and uh to play on for
tari whether to play C4 or can he
do and play Rook C8 let's say and keep
the tension because this is a very
critical question and if you decide to
play C4 maybe it's better to do it
immediately
because it can be very tricky I think
but the phone structure if if there will
be an exchange of phones but at the same
time I would be also considering that
maybe Rook C8 and after all I want to
take on D4 and possibly even in some
occasions I can sacrifice the D5 give up
the D5 Pawn for compensation
though it does not seem at first that
that will be the case but maybe CD4
at some point yeah I mean I guess the
question would be what happens uh where
do you go if I kick your knight
uh now because you can't jump into D3
any longer I guess you go back
do you take on D4 it's uh already
getting sharp right in this position
you'll have to take on D4 maybe you have
to take and if I take with the Knight
now you go back
but yeah I get it feels shaky I don't
really see how to benefit with white
if black is in time then you'll be
completely fine but even if for example
I play a move like Queen F3 or King F1
yeah I don't know uh something like this
yeah Queen F3 is a good question yeah it
feels like this porn you have to decide
what to do maybe you give it up as you
mentioned Judith uh you can kind of
flick in a check anytime you want but as
Magnus pointed out the king just sits
happily on F1 and maybe G2 bit later
but yeah I I like that decision I mean
my instinct though is uh never to be
like solid especially when I'm
commenting when I'm playing different
matter but when I'm commenting I'm like
yeah yeah unleash my inner Barbarian and
I'm just thinking you know can can like
white get try to get more
more tactical opportunities in that
variation you've actually you want to
attack yeah so okay well
and then it was Pawn takes A3 I like I
love that move A3 Pawn takes Knight
takes I was just I was just seeing a
Target in the middle of the board and
instinctively you know after Knight C6 I
was like could we go forward and try to
hit the D5 Pawn
and how do you do that I was thinking
five ah Knight B5 okay but then I think
D4
finally I can get rid of my phone and
then I'll just
get out of the way of any yes and also
there is another way instead of D4 to
capture on C3 first maybe and after
Knight C3 to play D4 before yeah
yeah and uh I will not take this one
because of course I get skewered but
instead yeah sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah
totally you have to show that sorry I
was just yeah I was just gonna say maybe
King F1 maybe you Castle I'm not sure
which one it's even Pawn takes Pawn as
well just uh well maybe that maybe I'm
just
sorry H to hg6 okay
and you want to make me you want to get
in somehow like this Checkmate the black
king
yes could happen
oh man I just like a person with a
one-track mind you know I just wanna I
see checkmates and I want to go for it
evaluation bar approves you Banker you
might have found the winning move now
you're threatening to take this Pawn now
you're threatening to drop back and
Checkmate yeah maybe white is just in
time maybe uh this whole line with
castling the black king uh we could
start to see the drawbacks now
yeah this is exactly was the problem
especially when black is giving up the
black Square Bishop
it can be immediately some pinpointing
the problems
yeah so it looks like out of everything
we've seen so far C4 is the best way to
give tari some counter play
okay and this game looks like it's
Brewing up very nicely it looks like
Fabiano is in good shape there and can
we go back to the bird's eye view and
revisit some of the other positions
because in the excitement of the Hikaru
Magnus we haven't really touched on too
many games like for instance
um well Magnus said that Wesley so and
against Anish giri would just end in a
draw
what do you think should we go and
investigate why he said this yeah let's
go because I think it's the moment where
uh we're gonna see some simplification
in that game
yeah at least we can do a quick
confirmation or quietly disagree who
knows maybe Magnus is wrong but I don't
think so we see Anish Gary on the camera
it looks like he's done a good job of
equalizing as black but no more than
that Wesley rock solid with the white
pieces this is the current position
let's do a quick action replay we did
miss the opening phase so let's see how
the Queens came off and uh let's
backtrack right to the beginning it was
another Queen's Gambit declined and uh
here after D4
we saw it this time it was uh the tarash
and okay this variation they call it the
Berlin of one D4 uh often white plays E4
here and uh yeah things get traded off
uh in this type of position uh the
Queens come off the board and the game
goes on but instead of Bishop G5
uh Bishop to E7 so now it's actually a
transposition to a reversed C3 Sicilian
a reversed alapin Sicilian which is uh
interesting white of course having the
extra Tempo black Central Pawn isolator
Pawn weak as usual and uh we saw the
black queen coming out and okay this is
how the queens were traded Queen A6
really clever move cutting across this
diagonal preventing white from castling
and if white can't Castle
you don't want the Queens to be on the
board so Queen to D3 and
yeah G5 pushing the bishop back in order
to gain the bishop pair black
eliminating the white dark Square bishop
and this is the current position Judith
any life here any life left
well I think
question is well white wants to get rid
of the the bishop pair of black so the
question is whether Bishop D4 or Knight
D4 will be played because I have doubts
that anything else can give black
an opportunity to play for a win in a
way let's say Knight E5 or something I'm
invited such a beautiful night blockade
on the E4 at the same time we shouldn't
forget that when you have two knights
only one can be standing on the E4 right
so that that's usually a problem but
after Knight E5 let's say Bishop F5 it's
very tempting to to place it there on F5
after that white can go B3 controlling
the C4 squared and I'm going to play
Rook C1 possibly improving my position
with F3 King F2 bringing their both of
my Rooks on the FIFA so I would think
that it's it's mainly white who can play
for a win so my question is whether how
to start to simplify the position
let's say if we take Bishop D4 starting
with that Knight D4 Knight D4 ed4 what
is this position can black be in any
danger I understand that the bishop on
E6 is biting into its own bones
at the same time if black brings the
king to G7 and F6 Rook CA took E8
can white improve significantly in this
position I don't think so
yeah this type of end game with all the
Rooks off the board arises in a variety
of different openings and that's just a
dead draws but uh you know it depends
whether white can do something with the
Rook still on maybe in conjunction with
F4
I mean it feels like it doesn't do too
much F4 but I can just simply kind of
put a Pawn on F6 sometimes but yeah I
guess that's this is the kind of
position that Gary is weighing up if he
can't be better you might as well go for
a position like this if you can kind of
guarantee in your mind that you will be
making a draw without too much pain
without too much suffering and Gary
looks like he's about to make a move
didn't want to go into the
simplification and just go to a very
boring game he wants to keep the tension
again we can talk about the tension part
right that you don't want to give up
because I can do that later as well
uh I don't think it's a bad move at all
maybe this is the best move uh Rook C8
because for a moment it seems that
no matter how wide gives up the tension
Knight E6 will not lead anywhere because
in it on C6 and Bishop on F6 is covering
extremely well the D4 Square so it seems
like there are later points where black
can decide and he wants to improve the
position before exchanging because well
maybe now Bishop has to be moving to B1
to not allow the exchange possibility
later
I think the whole position is pretty
much balanced for the moment yeah you
could definitely envisage a position
where neither side can really improve
their position
um just kind of comes to d8 the king
comes to G7 black can just sit and it's
very hard for white to do anything
that's that's very true but uh I mean I
I have to say I really love your Bishop
B1 by the way I I think it's great
because I have big plans for that Bishop
I would put it on A2
one once I once I but it would be like
the the cherry on top of the cake
because first of all the Rooks will come
to D2 and then double up and then and
only then when you have complete control
the bishop will come and then
isn't this like still something to
annoy blackwave yeah and I think it's
really important the point that Judith
made if black didn't have any Knights on
the board for example if let's say after
Rook D2 Blackwood to take then this plan
looks uh really strong really simple
just Rook D1 Push by two some point move
the Knight out the way and gang up
against this Pawn the problem is with
one set of knights on the board uh then
anytime this starts to happen the Black
Knight might start jumping into C4 if
you put a Pawn on A3 and
yeah it's uh it's the type of situation
where they say you always want at least
one of a kind the Bishops alone are
great for black but with a knight to
combine with them you get great chances
and likewise white doesn't want to be
the one initiating any trades because if
you take on C6 or E6 black gets a pawn
closer to the center joins up with that
D5 pawn and center and actually Black's
gonna be the one who's better so it
feels yeah I agree it's a nice plan but
it feels like it still has uh some
counter play for black these types of
positions absolutely and this is
probably a good time to take a quick
break but uh first up we have to mention
that the 2023 speed chess season has
arrived the junior speed Chess
Championship begins June the 13th this
four day event showcases the best young
talent in speed chess with over 45
000 on the line but the real prize goes
to the winner alone the top finisher
will move on to the main speed Chess
Championship later this summer don't
miss a moment of the junior speed Chess
Championship starting Tuesday June the
13th right here at twitch.tv forward
slash chess use xlam J
hercc in chat for all the details and
with that we're going to take it to a
break stay tuned because when we when we
return we'll break down all that
exciting chess action
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki andras
Toth everyone's favorite social media
troll known as Anish Geary and so many
more chessable can help you raise your
game to the next level you're getting
started on the fundamentals you should
check out everyone's first chess
workbook maybe you want to stop letting
all those points slip away in the end
game 100 end games you must know is the
course for you
did you not notice your king was in
check and still can't figure out why the
pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
fifty thousand chest muscles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
foreign
[Music]
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more longtime Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and Shakira mamat
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
hello and welcome back to all the action
in Stavanger and there you can see it's
a beautiful day the swans are out but no
players are swanning around in the
playing Court everyone is working hard
and I'm your host International Marcy
wankhauska and it's great pleasure as
always to have these guys in studio
legendary Grandmaster Judy poga and
David Howell a regular Grandmaster in
the corner it's good to be here Ivanka
I've got revenge for that eventually
we're just having fun aren't we
absolutely yeah it's been a fun day what
a day it's been so far I do feel bad
however we haven't got around to some
games too much uh it's been just
non-stop drama we've had results of
course we've had Nakamura against
Carlson two games actually in their
match the Armageddon being decided now
and Judith I know we really want to get
to the game between Mama draw and kukesh
and here we see them in the camera it's
a really tense battle over there they've
played out a number of moves already
really tense middle game they're at move
18 and uh this one could well could
fizzle out but it could get really
exciting if uh gukesh is feeling
ambitious here and actually it's manager
of intern story with white if he's able
to whip up some fire on the board so
let's jump in and discuss what's been
going on in that Clash
any favorites who did you predict before
the game to win
I said about the game
how it will be unfolded because of the
yesterday's round it was so difficult
for both players I think they were
sweating and they didn't turn out to be
good Mama jarov had a fantastic position
yesterday with black against firoza and
he was very upset when he ruined it not
only to a draw but actually he lost the
game and gukashvo gave a great fight and
he had opportunities against Nakamura uh
so for me it's very interesting and
curious how it will be developed I like
Black's position by the way he developed
very well his Rook just came to see it
so right now ready after move uh what is
it 18
uh all the pieces are out in development
yeah and a big question for Mama George
to answer right now there's a hit
there's a threat on his Pawn on C5
like you say black is fully ready but
does white steps point forward initiate
some uh trade some exchanges on C6 maybe
uh Mass simplifications on that square
or is there another way do we just kind
of retreat the night Amber really
reluctant it feels like that would allow
the black Bishop the blacklight Squad
Bishop to come out and uh yeah to a much
more active Square I don't know if there
are any tactics maybe in the position
that he's calculating right now right
and also if you step back with the
knighting it does allow black to
actually step forward with the pawn on
E5 as well so you it does feel that now
is the time to do something and of
course bailing out with C6
it's tempting you know at least you
guarantee yourself one point
the question is whether it's bailing out
or whether it offers an advantage to the
pawn to C6 uh you will get the bishop
pair it looks like with white if black
captures everything on that square and
the question is whether that's enough
Bishops can be extremely strong we've
seen that multiple times already this
tournament
um should we jump in what's happening
exactly see what happens after C6
so this is the first move that I think
any player would calculate just because
it's so direct so forcing uh here I
don't think black has an option you have
to take and I'm not sure it matters in
which way you take
now for white
I'm assuming Knight takes C6 here I take
C6 hitting two pieces black will
recapture yes because Knight E7 is a
threat
yeah and this is the first Junction
Queen takes or Bishop takes I kind of
want to take with the queen I'm not sure
why it feels uncomfortable the tension
but then again I'm inclined towards
Simplicity in my shoulders after Queen
C6 what happens if uh if Black Goes
Queen B8 yeah and you have to go between
B7 after that you'll be exchange you can
grab the pawn
oh clever tactics oh in A6 so I can take
on B2 because Rook C8 and after Rook C1
Bishop they see one exactly and I
understand that the bishop pair is no
longer like in the best possible shape
but opponent's Pawn Yeah Yeah we learned
that that if you have the opportunity to
grab a pawn there is no hesitation about
it right
any porn Grabber really salivates at the
thought of winning a porn even if you
have to suffer for a move or two with
the bad Bishop on C1 okay so after Queen
C6 then Queen C6 is kind of a must
Bishop D6 maybe also no Queen C6 and
then the question is whether white would
be probably taking with the bishop but
actually Rook D2 is coming in the next
move
do we have to maybe take with a rook and
let's say after another set of exchanges
Rook D2 can we just defend with Rook B1
I'm slightly reluctant to allow
counterplay on the king side with Knight
G4 but I'm hoping that I can jump out
the way with my bishop and
threaten your king maybe on the back
Rank and you know what we are gonna
actually see the players answer these
questions because C6 has been played
good cash
quick as a whip it did take on it with a
pawn
yeah and I think all of those moves are
well if not immediately forced then at
least the most logical the most direct
attempts
and we all see white with a bishop pair
the problem is if we follow this line
slightly further down I think Akashi is
going to take this Knight
there we go he makes the move we see on
the camera let's follow this line down
and
I mean the question is here for example
if the Rooks come off the board does
white have good winning chances
I would say yes I don't know I would go
Rook D2 and after Rook B1 probably
something like H5 to give some space for
my king on H7 and well anyway H5 these
days are the most common move and
somehow I prefer it there than on H6 but
white can go A4 let's say and and keep
an eye on the A6 bomb which probably he
wants to grab one day but how is the
counter play on the king side with
Knight to G4 as David mentioned yeah
yeah this is the question that's why I
also wanted to play H3 yeah that Knight
G4 in the next move it can come but the
only problem was for me that's why I
wanted to push A4 because I can move
with my Bishop right because the A2 Pawn
is under attack but maybe here black
will be completely fine and in time with
the counter play yeah maybe if H5 H3 is
you might mention that Ivanka and next
move A4 then we get out the way with the
bishop it's a lot of ifs it's a lot of
butts but
um if white gets everything then long
term I always told at least and from
experience this light Squad Bishop in
conjunction with enable one can be
extremely dangerous uh later in the game
so still some chances and uh if we go
back to the current position here maybe
here all these six can be an option or
you go to C1
yeah because my idea was to go to B6 and
to paint the Rock it all depends
that's extremely annoying that one
um you know Rook D6 maybe I also can go
back this direction and put the bishop
on B3 if I really need to break any pin
on the B file
this is the type of position I would
love to have against one of these top
guys because there's no risk for white
but the question is whether you win it
that's true and I'm not sure you win it
that many times out of uh out of 100 but
I think Mama drove made a good decision
there this is the current game position
after quintix C6 and kukesh he will spot
that Queen B8 it's impossible due to
quintix porn
yeah this is a very important part uh
that Olympiad is not possible and
practically black cannot avoid the queen
Exchange
it seems
yeah
this one came from the English opening a
bit of a strange branch of the English
opening but yeah go cash just so
impressive just it feels like he's
navigated to the opening really well
really solidly
and yeah I would love to see normal get
in between these two gotta say well
there is some chance but before that
moment jaro will press quite a bit I
think in this position yeah and it's
deceptive right the computer says uh
completely level 0.0 but it's only white
who can really claim an advantage well
maybe there are some concrete ideas
which can be the case
I don't see better than Queen takes C6 I
don't see a better version
than that
I mean the well yeah but in all of these
lines it's like black has to be accurate
and energetic and kind of precise just
to equalize right if black plays well
it's a draw if white plays well and
black makes two or three sips shouldn't
be that bad for black to be honest yeah
Queen takes C6 juvent Rook text C6 right
let's jump back in Queen takes C6
rotate C6 C6 and before we'd like dive
in with Rook takes C6 I just wanted to
ask you like you do have the opportunity
to trade works of course you can go
Bishop takes so just in general
how do you decide when to trade
and when not to
well I think in this position it becomes
very concrete so after Bishop C6 Rook D2
and the problem is for why that he
cannot avoid losing the A2 Pawn or he
has to exchange the bishop and give up
the black Square Bishop which leads to a
very droolish position okay yeah so here
there's a concrete reason I mean one
thing that I always think about is I
mean I win most of my games because I
have the bishop pair these days so I
don't know how to Checkmate I don't know
how to do anything else uh it's because
I get the bishop pair and grind my
opponents down and I just think uh the
Bishops they gaining power as the other
pieces leave the board so that's why I
would love to get all the Rooks off the
board that's why I'm kind of biased
towards getting one set of Rooks uh off
I would love to eliminate the last set
of Rooks and the Bishops on their own
they will dominate against the bishop
and knights still not sure whether it's
winning but uh yeah you'll be the one
having all the fun and as Judah says
whenever white ones who I can always
bail out with the draw going for
opposite color Bishops that's why the
bishop pair is so kind of delightful to
have no risk and a lot of potential
reward so yeah Bishops they gaining
power later in the game as pieces
disappear that's why I'm kind of
inclined towards in this position uh
Rook takes rather than Bishop takes and
those are instructive little rules that
you can use just to help you make those
decisions so yep Queen takes Queen on
the board
and I also quite like the way that both
these players are pausing before they
take these big decisions and I think
that's super instructive because it's so
easy for people just to kind of lash out
and just play instinctively the right
what they feel is the right move but as
we've seen time and time again sometimes
you miss golden opportunities by playing
automatic captures
yeah but I think both players know they
have more than an hour still on the
clock so there is no rush at all in such
a position it's much more important that
you're doing your moves and you think
that everything is under control you
made this move because there was no
other opportunity because Bishop Queen
B8 was not working
so this way it's much easier to move on
in the game
yeah and those Brooks are off the board
the position we predicted and just one
set of Rooks remaining black can get
active for for one move with Rook D2 but
it becomes very concrete after that can
black neutralize the small initiatives
that white would have in the ensuing
endgame it can be an idea you know to go
Rudy too and after a rook B1 to go H5
let's say and after that I would want to
go activate my knight to D5 but I see
that thought about it that it's better
to do it immediately
yeah makes a lot of sense there's a
small threat on the board of Knight to
B4 hitting the white bishop and hitting
the pawn on A2 uh really nice move and
yeah I think if he'd hesitated if he
dalied one or two moves white would have
had real chances for an advantage this
might be a uh Clincher I'm looking at
some tactics already as well like if the
bishop drops back to A4 let's jump in uh
if the bishop drops back Knight B4
hitting the pawn can white Klingon to
the A2 Pawn like this
feels like if you can just somehow get
rid of these two pawns on the a-file
dead draw of course pawns on just one
flank one side of the board
oh wow he hasn't gone for this okay
Rook to D1
is this one gonna fizzle immediately
dude is this going to be an instant draw
after Rook D1 Knight before night before
but maybe he's just uh
um
I I changed what I was gonna say maybe
just trade off works but of course you
cannot keep the A2 Pawn Yeah now the
bishop is attacked the pawn is attacked
double attack Knight Fork we're gonna
see Bishop B7 Knight takes everything
off the board and yeah as soon as the
Black Knight comes back it's a totally
different story now that the a pawns
have gone if the a pawns were still on
the board the Bishops would have uh
Targets on both sides but this time the
Knight is just as good as a bishop with
pawns only on the king side let's zoom
out of this one uh for a second because
it's going to be a draw I think let's go
to the player's cameras yeah no more
analysis needed
and uh how many moves have they made
they still have to repeat their moves I
believe
28 but not for long
and
what is he Retreats his Knight
yeah such a mature play I've got to say
from him I would have been panicking but
uh he neutralized it so easily
how are they going to find the
repetition before no he goes to D5 from
E7 yeah they only need to make two moves
here it comes here it comes exchange on
E7 he's going to allow that exchange
like G6 or something and then Bishop
takes Knight
and
that's it there will be a handshake
opposite color Bishops who's going to
offer the draw though that's the big
question looks like Shaq is ready
they didn't even they just nodded in
agreement and that was enough and a draw
has been agreed and this means that the
game between mama jarv and goo cash
will be decided by Armageddon I wonder
whether they were getting a telling off
from the Arbiter
yeah that they will be starting in 15
minutes yeah
usually the etiquette dictates that you
make a move and then you offer a draw it
was a mama jara's move he just nodded he
just kind of winked smiled and uh that
was enough the position was that drawn
dead drawn have you ever had that with
an opponent where you've you all you've
done is like smile and then you're kind
of like agreed that it was I'm too proud
Ivanka I forced them to make the move
then I just sit there mulling over their
offer showing them who's in control even
if I want to accept the offer you've got
to show them uh that you're not
desperate for that draw but these
players they want to preserve energy of
course and they want to get down to
business in the Armageddon and uh so
well that one will be happening in
roughly 15 to 20 minutes
and this means that we should check out
the bird's eye view and have a look at
some of the other games one that I'm
dying to revisit is the game between
Nordic abdisoturf against alireza farisa
because we even got the thoughts of
world champion a former world champion
Magnus Carl said
and uh he he thought that's farrugia was
slightly worse but would thrive in later
complications
yeah Magnus did say that first had been
taking risks at least strategically with
the black position in order to keep the
game alive to keep counter chances uh
obviously for a bit later on we do see
that the black queen has done a little
dance she was on A3 last we were here
now she's over on the king side on G5
but she's not really backed up not
supported by any pieces and black is
tied down the black Bishop tied down to
the C6 Pawn Jude at the Black Knight
tied down to the B6 Pawn
who would you pick here
oh it's not easy to say because it is
very nicely tied down the D7 Knight to
B6 spawn right from White's Knight on A4
which was just the last move
and which means that also the bishop
cannot be brought out through a through
C8
I would be thinking that maybe black
will be playing somehow Rook E6 bringing
up to the sixth Rank and then putting it
either to F6 or just keep it on on E6
and then it can the bishop can move away
but still black has to solve this
problem that how to get out of the box
whether C5 anytime it's possible or
black and just completely forget about
that looking for counter chances open up
C5 D takes Knight D5 or something but it
seems like it that it's it's not easy
to loosen up the situation for black
yeah and this is I guess why they say in
a Carlsbad structure dictated by these
uh pawns for black on c65 and these
pawns for white on E3 D4 uh usually you
don't really ever want to touch the
people and normally the B6 Pawn would be
back on B7 and black species would be
free to do what they wanted in the
center or on the king side but yeah for
now he's really lacking that extra minor
piece if there were dark squared Bishops
on the board I think that's why Magnus
was so surprised by that trade if black
okay rookie six on the board if black
had a bishop won D6 it would kind of
give attacking chances it would kind of
stop white from advancing on the queen
side as well but yeah right now maybe I
would be hesitating maybe it's something
very bad which I'm going to ask if my
plan is let's say to go Rook D6
eventually the main idea is to move the
bishop to C8
and after that to play B5 I push your
knight to C5 and then Knight F6 so I
play double or nothing I start playing
on the king's side so if my Bishop can
be on open up midnight F6 then it can
attack a little bit uh towards the H3
Pawn I understand that it's not
something that I can be very proud of
giving up the C5 Square after B5 it's uh
it's just thinking about something
concrete stuff
yeah I like yeah it was interesting I've
actually seen that kind of idea done
before
so it's not entirely out of the box I
kind of like it yeah I remember I played
a game against Essie panko in the grand
Swiss once and it was basically this
exact uh simple instruction that
happened to me I've never been so
shocked in my life as when he played B5
in a position like this I was like wait
are you committing strategic suicide but
then I realized wait he's just giving me
one square in return he's getting so
much activity and keeping all the pieces
on the board
yeah it's not something you want to do
with black but it's a kind of
desperation from some point with you
right right now I cannot play real it's
not included in the game the B7 Bishop
at all and the D7 Knight is also not
taking part so much so with the A4
Knight right now two pieces are
paralyzed kind of and what about as an
Ulta I I love your plan but what else
what about as an alternative just simply
to double on the e-line and
David no it's David no yeah and now you
know exactly what's coming next yeah
completely fine with that okay five
yeah it makes sense while the White
Knight is kind of sidelined distracted
kind of tying down Black's pieces on A4
to strike on the other side of the board
yeah I'm always reluctant to push my F1
but here I don't yeah I don't see
anything wrong with that one especially
that after F5 wrote G6 also can be kind
of unpleasant for white
and it's very much up ferrugia's uh
Street there it's up his alley to go for
some kind of activity what may be right
we'll stop this and play Queen C2 for
example now
but
should we jump in because uh there's a
couple of things I want to see here
first question
is Abdus gonna play an extremely
ambitious move uh I'm really trying to
work out right now whether it's
I mean yeah before it's too late push
the pawn to B4 and uh nice one
yeah I mean it's either very good or
black maybe you want to take Knight B6
right
you read my mind you know I'm just
trying to work out whether it's uh I
mean maybe It's tricky because Queen
Knight B6 Knight B6 Queen B4 C5
and then the E4
yeah there's some I was trying to do
some nasty stuff but you'll write D4 D4
E4
to point out threatening Checkmate E4
and now
you can come back maybe well you can go
to G6 or or yeah six also possible it's
interesting our Styles you want to check
mate which I should really be looking at
I'm I didn't even have that on my radar
I just wanted to draw back and pin and
defend my Bishop but that looks a bit
sad uh probably just Rook B1 so yeah I
mean such a crazy position I just
spotted a tactic and I'm not sure it
quite Works
um but before in the current position I
mean worst case uh scenario where it
just takes back and still same for some
threats
yeah we have Queen A2 on the board okay
so instead of this nice idea which you
offered yeah I mean it was just fantasy
my variations there maybe two ambitious
instead going back to the game Queen to
E2
what is the idea here
I guess a hinting at a kind of queen
trade hinting maybe that he'll come to
A6 and trade off Black's Bishop
or maybe he just wants to have the queen
closer right and only after this
Possibly play Rook C2 doubling on the C
file or playing Rook C to Rook B1 and B4
and what about your plan of playing B5
is that something
to consider but I wouldn't like to
exchange the knights I think so after B5
Knight C5 then we have to exchange the
knights
right but if you just simply say you
know what I got one bad piece but the
rest of my pieces are quite nicely
placed isn't that a good compensation
yeah one bad piece makes a position bad
and here there's no activity against the
white king if there was activity maybe
but uh yeah if Judith you also mentioned
uh for example maybe ensuring that
um
the night survived and for example here
it might be hard to arrange I was going
to say first drop the bishop back and
then your idea was B5 in a situation
like this right yeah
and now you can run away from the trade
suddenly things have opened up six yeah
this this was kind of the idea
yeah so interesting stuff uh it does
feel kind of like you said
counter-intuitive to allow a knight to
land on this beautiful outpost on C5
launching pads there but the real thing
is for black I mean you go King F1 let's
say or King
each one right you know the move that I
want to play
F4 F4 nearly traps the queen yeah nearly
no I'd actually just wanted to get rid
of the Queens because I feel that white
has great chances in the end game
hmm makes a lot of sense as well
I mean these positions they're so rich
they're just so tense uh just one Pawn
push from either side and the dynamic
could completely change but this is a
big question for example if let's say
black exchanges the queen we have to I
think you have to
and let's say I go H5 I don't want your
G4 around we know you already
[Laughter]
so we don't allow G4
and there is a beautiful night on C5 but
how can you regroup it the way that
you're happy to D3 to E5 because then
there's an E4 Square
it's not so easy to is this where you
start chipping away at the other end
like A4
and Black Blocks I guess B4
yeah
surprise you thank you you're not
pushing pawns on the other side I would
want to play F5 King F3 King F4 G4 I
didn't even know such a plan existed
like now you've enlightened me David
scrap A4 and that is where I will have
my eyes on I don't know I mean it's
interesting this position right this
bishop is a bit dead on C8 but both
sides have given each other squares
probably just in the balance but
Anything Could Happen serious
maneuvering starting yes yeah so let's
go back to the current position it is
after Queen E2 if the Queen's disappear
the type of thing we just showed could
well be relevant but still uh that in
itself is a big decision
any Queen trade would completely change
the nature of the game and I don't think
it would be a happy decision for Abdul
sotor who wants to go for that attack as
Magnus said who wants to keep the
tension go for something dynamic
yeah and maybe I've just realized that
abdusitoris plan is actually to trade
off Queens you know maybe he's
threatening Queen to G4
with the idea of Bishop F5 if the queen
train is the client
yeah he's at least hinting right yeah
that's always useful as uh as we've Jude
it I think you said in previous days the
threat stronger than the execution
sometimes you kind of play a move like
this queen G4 might not be a threat
maybe it backfires but you get your
opponent thinking about it for 5-10
minutes and then you get your opponent
to think about Bishop A6 for five ten
minutes and they start kind of seeing
ghosts yes well okay well this game is
also looking to be super interesting
especially in the later stages but can
we go back to the birds I viewed because
I'm just going to ask you your opinion
on some
of the other games so there are two that
kind of spring to mind first of all
Fabiano caruana against ariantari has
Ariane survived the worst of it and then
my second question is the game between
Wesley so and Anish giri
is that gonna head into draw because
there's been some changes
yeah interestingly enough we left the
position where Anish played Rook C8
maybe we can go back to that point
because he was postponing this exchange
on D4 but later on he did not find
anything better than that idea right and
somehow he did exchange things on on D4
yeah and uh as you mentioned Judith
Let's do an action replay from the
moment we love last left the game about
five moves ago and uh let's jump in it
was here black played uh Rook a to C8
for a logical move F3 an idea you
mentioned Judith just bringing the white
king closer uh very nice kind of
strategic move long term as you said
found nothing better than trading
everything off this position looks drier
than uh paint but right now after King
F2 suddenly things burst into life and
it was here after a set of Rooks came
off uh Wesley found the move Rook to C5
and uh he's saying yes we can trade but
it's on my terms if you trade Rooks now
it's not gonna be good for black because
the white King has a clear path into the
center White's pawns are connected
outside majority and white will likely
win this end game so his hand was
forcedent rather than play a move such
as Bishop E6 which looks solid enough to
me
Gary provoked Wesley by playing B6 he
provoked him to take this Pawn any Rook
trade there would have been a draw with
the symmetrical Pawn structure and now
Bishop E6 Rook E5 back support down so
but not for long we should wait two is
taking or is he does he have plans of
does he finesse it does he start with
the movement to d8 but then the king the
white king will step forward to E3 and
maybe that help White
yeah do you feel Anish just relaxed a
bit too early he thought ah this is
going to be a draw anyway no I don't
think you can be so superficial at this
point he has to understand and know what
he is doing
uh I think he just he thought that he
wants maybe a little bit more
interesting end game not this
symmetrical so that's why he was pushing
B6 because he felt that giving up the D5
Pawn for the A2 it he's not risking
anything which I'm not sure he is
completely right because indeed rookie 7
is going to be pushed
uh on the sevens and then if the pawn is
going to be playing A5 then you go to B7
yeah and twice d-pawn is potentially
very strong uh if it could start
advancing though still Rook C6 and how
can white proceed black will work C6
Rook D6 black king comes G7 F6
maybe it's just that white puts the
bishop on e4 she just kind of brings the
king black is very stuck
yeah I should be solid enough you would
think but uh it definitely feels like
Anish has taken a bit of a risk and he
goes back with Rook d8 so in the current
position not taking here yet first
starting with Rook d8 I don't know what
that changes to be honest after King to
E3 I see something and it's a small
thing once the king steps to E3 The Rook
on E5 doesn't have too many squares
like squares the promise we can't attack
it yet I know it's annoying isn't it
Yeah well black can go Rook D6 for
example
but after Rook D6 A3 F6 and the direct
B5 yeah it's a Pity that we're taking
this uh allows a check otherwise
otherwise I'd be able to pin you along
this diagonal I didn't I didn't see that
one happy accident
that route B5 and yeah pulling up for
white not the best Pawn in the world
it's isolated it's controlled for now
but
opponent support it's suddenly Wesley
who's the only player who can win this
game right now a niche fighting for the
draw
and I do expect Wesley in the game
position just to
improve his King why not yeah King E3
Bishop A2 rookie seven
and then okay let's move on the way we
expected before A5
yeah
and
what could give white an advantage here
I don't know because the Black Rock
seems to be so good on D6 yeah just to
show you
Great PC on D6
is it not King E4 I just want to advance
and come in but uh yeah this doesn't
look like it should work
it feels like there's something here I'm
joking you want to go kinky four I was
half jerking I just saw the evaluation
bars on white side and I don't
understand why
[Music]
let's see if you can make me treat it
maybe
56 King F5
I mean you're provoking me yeah that's
how I play chess okay three Bishop E4
right and then you want to go King F6
and you want to check I want to check
with you
guys I'm gonna interrupt you and say
there's still obviously a lot of fun to
be had in this position but I do have to
take it back to the bird's eye view
because we do have an Armageddon game
that is on the verge of starting and of
course that is between the most creative
Grandmaster around shakuria mamajov
against one of the what Young and
upcoming talents
just 17 years old
and he is getting in the zone ready to
play Armageddon and of course the rules
of Armageddon they're very simple and
they are very fast white will have 10
minutes on the clock black will have
seven minutes and
the players do get an extra increment
after move 40
and here you go here's the graphics that
I wanted and it will be one and a half
points for a win and one point for a
loss but the most important thing about
Armageddon is that black will win with a
draw and I cannot for the life of me
remember what we predicted in this game
or the other games
but uh what do we think
yeah in the Armageddon I was so
impressed by mama jarov uh in his game
against Terry two days ago where with
white he sacrificed a porn early he
played quick fast confident chess even
though it was speculative even though it
was potentially unsound what mama jarov
was doing he put pressure on the
opponent on the board and clock and he
was repaid with a win so I'll say mama
jarov a favorite book Kesh he's a
different kettle of fish of course and
he never gets nervous I think it will
depend very much on the opening because
if if Mama jaro will be able to get the
opening of a messy complicated
uh full of action kind of position
then I think he he would be definitely
the favorite if it's going to be a very
balanced game as it was in the classical
game I would put my money on
okay
welcome getting uh seated there
um good cash is certainly a different
kettle of fish as David said you know
because for one thing he has a very
tactical very fighting style he's not
going to be afraid of entering into
those complications or the chaos that
mamajarov will be looking at in
initiating but on the other hand we have
actually seen on for instance the
Champions chest tour that Mama jorov can
be an exceptional end game player and
let's take a look at some of gookash's
impressive stats
he is number 17 on the feed 8 world
ranking that's just incredibly
impressive when you think about the fact
that he is just 17 years old for David
and myself who were still at school but
Judith you're already Conquering the top
of the world at that age but uh good
cash is third youngest Grandmaster in
history and fearsome competitor
yeah every time you say it you think I
think of that Stevie Nicks song Edge of
Seventeen and uh okay we're off it's the
English opening the symmetrical English
this was the uh this was what was played
in the opening of their classical game
earlier today so a repeat so far until
this last move
striking out in the center E5 I've
played this move when I was a kid ah
fond of memories yeah I remember when I
was sneaking into my sister Susan's big
room where she was studying and I was
maybe 10 years old or something and I
was supposed to be telling them E5 C5
grid D6 Bishop G7 Knight G7 Bishop E6 no
no no no there is a weakness on D5 don't
talk and then I was insisting
and did you play it in throughout your
career did you stick with it a lot with
the C5 E5 system after I'm not saying
it's the best way but I uh I played it
and what about this now you have A5 and
now we have H4 and uh quick as a flash
gkash just says H6 I'm gonna meet H5
with G5 and surprisingly enough no games
in the database new territory
I think it's uh it's a good sign for
Mama jarov this position I think he
couldn't think of something nicer than
this
yeah it could transpose back to may
maybe more kind of Mainline Theory here
it's common nowadays to throw forward H4
did they do that back in your day when
you were playing no no they were
positional D3 Castle Knight D1 92 93
Knight D5 and they claimed that just
because they have the d5v square
controlled they are better
[Laughter]
I I think I've told my students that at
some point yeah
little do they know that there's more to
chests than one square exactly one
weakness is not a killer
and they call this the bot Clinic Pawn
structure at least when white has it
this uh kind of clamp that black has on
C5 d65 very solid stuff look at that
there you go Knight E3 on the board
cash answering quickly he's He's Surely
going to Castle now I don't see any
attack that white can create with this
Pawn on H4
well and after having the pawn on H4
white will not have that plan to play
castle and F4 E4 or something sometimes
in other positions
yeah H6 are very useful move for black
H4 questionable for white but there we
go shoot it commentators this is what I
thought there for is not an option after
H4 but that was wrong that's the one
thing I've learned from commentary if
you say a move's not going to happen it
will happen guaranteed okay so the movie
want to make it happen we just say
that's how it goes it's a black
definitely won't play King h8 oh oh
and guys he's going for it there was a
poll
where we asked who will win this
Armageddon cash with black or Shaq with
white and uh well the poll was quite
convincing
they said that good cash would win with
black at 64 percent
wow I guess he does have two results up
his sleeve a draw or a win that's kind
of 66 of the results uh are in his favor
so it makes a lot of sense and uh these
guys very balanced in the classical
portion but suddenly for the first real
time kukesh is having to sink into a
thing and I like what he's doing Judah I
must say mama jarov he's asking big
questions breaking up black structure
already very flexible with White's King
as well absolutely it's a very much
piece of bread I am completely sure
about that
and and many times he he's really just
playing with intuition right H5 I don't
know if he takes it or I will take on G6
I just want to go
but another question is whether
mamajaro's King whether is it going to
be in safety any part of the game
he doesn't care about his own King he's
locked in and focused on the enemy king
that's Shakira in a nutshell and okay
Black's coming in Knight D4 so he's uh
okay question mark attached to that move
what's his idea I don't know I mean my
first instincts is kick kick that night
away
I mean could it be he's thinking about
Bishop takes Knight no he's not he just
wanted to provoke E3
wow mysterious stuff if he wanted to do
that so after FDX E5 and hg6 the Bishop
from C1 is blocked so it cannot capture
the pawn on H6 but I'm not sure you can
really do this giveaway two tempies like
that because now the queen is coming to
H1
my major is having fun you see the kind
of finesse he put on playing that last
move kind of drilling the queen into the
square on the board
yeah it feels like two Tempe giving up
two whole moves there for black I don't
believe in Knight D4 giving two temp is
this way I mean the queen was invited
right to H5 he didn't want to he didn't
have to anyway I think E3 was didn't
move
what the mama jar of had to play
and it's not as if this one C1 is closed
forever it could well come to life later
on with a timely E4 break and uh it
could break through eventually on this
diagonal to the weakness on H6 watch out
for that one later Bishop D2 he wants to
Castle long G4 Rook G one Knight E4 I
don't know but it looks scary
I'm terrified and uh well
you see Gucci retreating with his Bishop
getting ready to attack the White Queen
Queen drops back still scary stuff I
mean how is black gonna untangle black
has no active possibilities whatsoever
he's just waiting for white to initiate
the attack
well prop B5 yeah wow expecting this
he's going all in though go cash this is
a sacrifice but he has to go for counter
chances for sure otherwise he's going to
get checkmated
yeah I think you're right Judith this is
where these young players are so good at
spotting the dynamism and I think that
move is top of your radar top of your
instincts for me I find it extremely
difficult I'd have to kind of sit down
work out that giving up this Pawn is
Justified but you're right good thing is
in Armageddon you just don't think you
play right true only four minutes on the
clock I I'm not scared guys
yeah and I mean I would just capture the
Knight and then I would take on B5 with
my own Knight and I would say
I'm pulling up
the other thing is that Knight E7 then
Queen takes E7 and if Knight B5 then he
takes F4 and there is a bit oh what no
he took back with the Knight wow E4 he
is opening up this bishop it looks like
a Miss according to the uh computer here
with the cross the Red Cross there that
we see but that's not because it's a bad
move it's a decent move it's just maybe
there was something
Nation we have with the pawns look at
that force and the fifth row it's like
who takes who
it's like two armies and they're
basically like standing you can feel
their breath on your face
it's a scrum and yeah I can I completely
agree with that comment there mind games
and such a tense position but it feels
so dangerous for kikash and take a look
at the clock time
it's just over three minutes and White's
forces are lined up against that H6 Pawn
that H6 Pawn is in danger but also
White's king take a look at that also
not safe
whose King is going to be mated it feels
like one of these Kings is doomed it's
yeah they're apparel right now problem
isn't Queen D3 I think Impossible on
simply Rook D1 and the king queen can be
in trouble
King F2 look at that and there is a
queen trap yep that would have been a
queen trap against the black queen if it
had captured instead a move with a
question mark a mistake from gokash
Bishop to G6 looks natural he's escaping
with his King if he really needs to Last
Resort there but maybe there's a killer
blow here a knockout for Mama jarov this
is so
type of game there is no way he will
he will not Shuffle things the way that
it will be victory for him yeah and he
has the time to figure his way out of
this deep dark Forest he has just under
six minutes on the clock and lots of
captures they can play Bishop takes
Bishop you can get porn taste Pawn you
can even Castle your king to safety
alongside yes of course safety
wow he's uh I was gonna say is he gonna
castle that no he doesn't Castle on the
short side because that could be Trevor
maybe for a check right so King on E1
that's the real
real safety nowadays it's all about a
pain keeping the options open with the
white king to go long later on he's
delayed it I once castled on move 37
Queen side will Mama jarov break that
record Rook to F1 and this is nasty huge
threats as well Bishop D5 in the air
with a nasty check but what about Queen
D3
yeah he has to play and uh good cash
have course has found the most active
move E5
the black king is gonna start running
but maybe but maybe you should uh leave
that uh King on F7 because it stops The
Black Queen checking on E3 but I'm
afraid that if Bishop D5 you don't have
a good spot where do you go King E7 yeah
Queen G6
23 Knight D2
wow and it just masses there about
whether black can deliver a killer blow
I don't know probably they're simply
Knight D4 Black's Rook is also coming
down to B2 in some of these lines
and well Shaq now under five minutes on
the clock and this position is insane
and remember they don't get any
increment until move 40 so still 12
moves to go and even then only a one
second increment and in this chaotic
position in this melee it's going to be
so tough to navigate this game is going
to be decided in the next few moves Shaq
needs to invest his extra two minutes
now and so many options Judith you
mentioned maybe bishop check
and then Rook F3 first just to make sure
that there's no Ah that's all so cool
move yeah and Rooks F3 hitting kicking
away this black queen looks very
sensible I'm also maybe looking at oh D1
doesn't quite work here there's still
some tactics
in the ah he needs to do something if
the black king moves the White Queen
is going to be attacked
he needs to break the pin in a favorable
way right now Mama jarov He's
calculating your move Bishop D5 checks
surely we're taught that way checks
captures and threats in that order
Bishop D5 check is the first one you
look at if it's good you play it yeah if
not you've rooted out go for something
else right and black also has the idea
of actually playing Queen takes G3 check
so I do feel that Bishop D5 is quite a
natural move
the thing is that he cannot play Bishop
D5 now he has to calculate what's the
next move so that's why he's thinking
Bishop D5 King E7 what will be my next
move right okay it's on the board on the
board he takes the bishop the line you
mentioned earlier it's on the board
after a two minute think but good cash
for sure was investing his time thinking
what about Queen F1
oh but it's not no wow and you see the
bar drop
is that a winning move I don't think so
because takes Knight H4 Queen F7 right
and
while this move has been given a double
question mark Queen takes G6 black can
take on F1 now take that white Rook
trick the white king onto the f file
discover check Knight H4 hitting the
White Queen I mean F7 so it's not
something you know I think we need three
stupid
okay but what next that's the question
for Rook B2 simply it's one of those two
moves to Queen E6 yeah there is no more
check Rook B2 where he's reaching for
his Queen he's gonna go Queen E3 check
and the Knight is gonna block that check
but uh I think it's your move David of
oh no 94.
now there's gonna be more checks oh
wow 94 question mark missing potentially
a win I think it was that root takes B2
Ivanka the black king would have been
able to dance its way to safety while
the white king would have been mated now
Knight D4 on the board okay Queen takes
C2 is a Checkmate threat
do you have up your sleeve how does
white defend this one or maybe you just
have to give the checks
and maybe but of course let's check and
hope for the best the draw is as good as
a loss for Shaq
High School cash got this one in the bag
move 31 not too much time left on the
clock one and a half minutes full kukash
Bishop takes C4
I have a feeling what gets checkmated in
a lot of these variations but
you just gotta gamble at some point I
think I mean you also have ideas of for
black this is a rook takes work and then
the other Rook will swing oh there's so
many unpleasant possibilities and Shaq
fighting for survival he is in a must
win situation
Shack not on the attack anymore it is
kukesh who wants to Checkmate and yeah
he needs to step back he needs to defend
he needs to do something Shaq still time
Advantage for 30 seconds up on the clock
here well maybe between G7 to start with
and after King D6
to go Bishop C4 yeah yeah I think I
think you have to rule out that trade of
Rooks
I mean you could also start with Bishop
C4 maybe but I agree with the feature
chat a moment ago uh firstly this one
the queen G7 is natural but a moment ago
it said ignore the engine because this
is just chaos it's just a gamble uh
neither side is C4 yeah neither side is
knowing what's going on really they
don't care about the evaluation they're
just trying to survive
oh at least there's no chat mates for
now yeah yes and uh here it comes Rook
takes porn
there are track mating ideas on the
board though Knight takes Knight big
threat I think Rook takes Knight is even
a bigger one yeah I think you hit the
nail on the head you've anchor the
problem for White is you have to do
something you can't defend any longer
yes you can check the black king forever
but that's just the draw you need to win
yeah
forgot to Castle okay a check he's
taking Pawns
as long as the black king dances to Safe
squares
okay he's put himself on a light Square
I'm surprised by that but it looks safer
now
he needs to keep moving quickly no
hesitation one minute and a few seconds
still no increment for the players
Checkmate threatened within two moves of
black white needs something quickly
I don't see it I don't see a defense
problem is for white he has nothing
better than to give checks
it should be a draw with best play
manager if he just needs to gamble he
needs to find a way to keep the game
going at any cost
gives another track
and another check
black king going to move five
oh for Judith
into the lion's den no he wants to
maintain the balance and puts his King
back to D7
will Mama jarov continue with the checks
will he Retreat the White Queen he needs
to try something he's going to check
from all the possible squares but he's
the one lower on the clock now
it's going to be physically difficult to
keep the game going let alone make the
moves save time on the clock
keep tracking
I'm just thinking under 20 seconds
I promise kukash has found the perfect
squares for the king nothing to do for
white
it's just to draw best player
oh he's running he's running he's this
is where he risks it but Rook takes
Knight the black Rook can capture right
yeah
he didn't damage his position anyway he
has the Apache check which leads to
victory for cash right
still go Knight takes night because
there's no way white can introduce a new
piece into the attack but he's actually
closed rook and then here come the
checks whoa what a game
he's hovering around the town second
mark
and he's giving all the checks but he's
not repeated the position three times
yet Mama jarov he's expecting rukesh to
retreat and the question is what next
for mama jarov can he activate the white
Rook does black have a threat wow
finally Bishop King C5 Bishop A6 look at
that
made the move there's no Checkmate yet
for what
another track mate and look at that
black king out in the open leading from
the front manager of leaning back
nervously looking at the score sheet uh
he realizes he gets a one second
increment now
continues the checks the white Rook
cannot enter the action that's the issue
black has to watch out for his Rook not
to step on the B file
yeah he's finding safe squares so far
five seconds for Mama jarov
to do is just to draw he's checked from
nearly all the possible squares now and
could cash finding safety one what a
move oh wow Queens are off the board the
game goes on still some chances
and the players agree to a draw meaning
kukesh takes the points
he wanted it so much yeah you could see
the relief
motion and uh well congratulations to 17
year old kukash that was an explosive
Armageddon game with it livening up in
those last seconds what a position what
a difficult position he got into after
move 15 or so
yeah he still has emotions
so impressive the youngster getting
those emotions out now sitting at the
board setting things up really calm The
Iceman
taking the points my major are so close
but not close enough
and wow it feels like we've had so much
action today but still three classical
games ongoing
it's like a buffet this uh Norway chess
event
well well when you have players like
this I mean we are in for a treat every
single day and these are crazy
happenings you know in the meantime
between no deerback and Fairuza should
we revisit those games
yeah let's take a look let's go around
the horn and update ourselves on the
three classical games in progress uh we
see farrugia that deep in thought this
one has exploded as he said shoot it I
felt like something was brewing it felt
like the Calm before the storm when we
left it and now with the players still
around the 45 minute Mark Anything Could
Happen black has given up a pawn though
it was for Russia who decided to
initiate these tactical Sparks and okay
let's jump into the position
and we'll do a recap there's only been
three moves since we were last year but
three big big uh moves in the grand
scheme of the game and this is the
position just to do a quick recap let's
jump in and queen E2 was where we left
it C5 immediately
we mentioned it as an idea maybe not in
this exact position but D takes C5 D4
Cheap Trick spotted Queen takes G2 is
going to be a Checkmate but it was
blocked and ferusia's just dropped back
with the black queen yeah because it's
interesting that if I couldn't go E4
just to block the bishop because simply
B takes E5 would be the move
right so very interesting idea by firoza
to play C5
yeah and what do you make of this
avoiding the queen trade black is
temporarily a pawn down but now he has
counter play he's hitting the E3 Pawn
he's hitting the C5
yeah and so
it becomes very tricky this position
yeah white has three or four captures I
think we can rule out Queen takes D4
just because of Knight to E5 and there's
a skewer the White Queen orbit will drop
so we can rule that one out for white uh
like you said 46 Pawn impossible because
if it takes you one Bishop F5
hmm
Hit The Rook and now I can gain time
against the White Queen I'm not sure how
I want to do that 95 Knight F6
one of these two moves
I say Knight to F6
Knight F6 when H4 let's say let's start
with that one now again time against
your Bishop Maybe
okay fine
yeah next move if given time I can just
take on C5 I can take if I would have
gone to f word and you would chase me
further with your knight or what
maybe I was also wondering about
either 85 or G5 G5 I I wanted Ivanka to
say a G5 on the board push those Pawns
I'm gonna let you do that one I was
tempted to try and be a bit clever with
rookie five first and then G5 but it
feels like yeah I might as well flick it
in first uh maybe G5 here
but still so complicated
what a position
So Random everything hanging the White
Queen hanging the Black Rock hanging so
let's see if instead of Bishop F5 is
there any other move forward
um the first move that kind of like
calls my gets my attention is moves like
Knight takes porn
huh
I I know I know I know there's a Pawn on
E3 that's dropping and I can see that
the bar says Nope that is going to be a
losing move maybe Knight takes C5 35 is
the problem yeah okay hitting the bishop
and now your knight is no longer
protected well that's the case I mean
how is Pawn takes Pawn then yeah uh
maybe that's the one that he's trying to
calculate right now
um he's definitely looked at Knight
takes Knight as you mentioned Ivanka we
always have to look at all these
what's wrong with this I think simply
Knight E5 capturing on the 3D takes easy
Yeah okay or we need to do these three
yep just for example as you say one of
these
the queen has hit suddenly everything is
crushing into ruins around the white
king
yep that was very convincing so let's
rewind thank God we're just analyzing
and this isn't actually a game but I
mean this is the type of
a way that white could easily go wrong
one bad move and that's it you could be
out so maybe Queen E2 after all was not
a good decision by uh not their back you
know because this is a very nice
energetic idea for black yeah and it
feels like the stakes are extremely high
for weight with black you're going to
win the pawnback white is the one kind
of balancing on that tightrope and the
Knight on A4 is now very much needed
would be needed on the king's side right
because it's just out there
if you could put it on F4 for example
you'd just be winning with white five
anywhere around the king side yes and
what about random moves like E4 I mean
no 95 is no no ignore ignore ignore I've
fallen for that once that E4 is not
possible because Knight D5 Queen moves
away Knight takes D3 and then Bishop
takes on e4 right so
threat 95 in general hitting the bishop
hitting the queen and
yeah scary stuff right now but actually
maybe it's still possible to make why
don't we check it after E4
yep let's jump back in yeah E4 suggested
here and I mean first of all black could
just maybe just take on C5 if you want
to keep things stable but you take C5
and then only then threaten Rook G6 or
Knight E5 but that's true threat is the
threat stronger than the execution first
this is the most direct hitting the
Queen the queen oh not there Rook G6
Queen E2
and now we want to take and to take
and it's white just
it looks horrible yeah I mean it looks
scary oh Queen D2 it's not the end of
the world just because it looks a little
scary
I don't like horror movies dude anything
that scares me I still well clear of
but yeah you're right actually there's
no uh kind of knockout it feels like
this G2 square is so tender but no way
to break through that yeah and
yeah this this doesn't look so pleasant
but I I just checked the analysis so the
engine bar and the engine says that um
if white wants to maintain equality
Bishop F5 only move
oh and going down that variation yeah
this is what we started
you're Instinct student your first
instinct
and I guess maybe first instinct for
Nordic as well just backing it up with
calculation and I'm sure he's very
unhappy what has happened in the last
few moves yeah and it's fascinating
Magnus sat there in that chair just what
was it an hour ago and he said
taking risks because it will explode at
some point he will at some point get
activity and I love I was laughing
inside I was like it's the most boring
position ever Black's passive Black's
got no pieces to attack with and
suddenly this has happened
these top players they know everything
yeah Bishop F5 if that's the only move
to maintain the balance
I fearful not to back
yes but I don't understand why is it so
good that's my only problem well it's
just a question of survival right as
they and there is another move that it
says but black will get a slight
advantage and that's to go Queen F4 but
that looked very odd to me
no that looks unnatural somehow
I guess it's just getting out the way of
any night jumps but
a difficult one to find to quina for
maybe the idea is to jump into C7
in certain positions
yeah oh well we will have to leave Abdus
as he Ponders over how he came mint can
maintain the balance in that particular
position and we need to take a breather
we need to refresh our cups of teas and
coffees and we are going to go into a
short break but we do have to mention
that it is a perfect time to join the
official chess.com Community Club this
is the place to be for all info on
community tournaments giveaways contests
and other events plus connect with the
community and stay up to date on the
Chess World use xlam community in chat
to get in on the action and we we will
be back into the action right after this
break
oh my goodness 98 whoa
the chance Rook F7 oh no
no no
[Music]
foreign
to our new video lecture series here
with the one and only the 14th World
chess champion vishwanathon and on if
you have to explain that your world
champion and it's taking longer than two
words there's something wrong with your
friends
there's something wrong but I believe in
when we're talking the 60s and 70s even
the 80s and 90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where
I was trying to tone it down
not get very excited and also I had not
had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
a draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um we got to grab this chance with both
hands because it's not going to come by
way
[Music]
foreign
Norway land of fjords Majestic mountains
Cliffs and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alereza farouza
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more longtime Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and shakuria Mami
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
hello and welcome back and we hope
you're refreshed and ready for the next
part of the round because things are
heating up as time starts ticking down
I'm your host International Master
Ivanka houska and as always it's been
such a wonderful pleasure to have here
in the studio with us Judith poga part
of History a legend and someone who's
watched it all from the commentary desk
Grand Master David Howell I'm sorry
David last one I promise it's a pleasure
I'll take it I'll take what I can get
it's a pleasure to be here to you it's
been quite fun
and uh we've seen so much action so far
today two games now decided in the
Armageddon what have I thought so far
we've had some time now to uh catch our
breath and uh kind of mull things over
yeah I mean it's been quite a fantastic
start where first of all we had that
short and sweet game by Hikaru and
Magnus and then like wild Kings Indian
and of course the second game going to
Armageddon between mamajarov and gokash
and that one was quite mad if I have to
say so peace is Flying Wild tactics and
let's actually hear more from kukash and
say what he thought of things during
that game
hey you guess it ends up being quite the
hectic Armageddon game there yeah yeah
it was super exciting I
um
this was not what I had planned before
the game but suddenly when we reached
this position I thought okay I'll try
this opening which was not part of the
plan but I guess it worked out well but
I was but I just missed H5 in the
opening and I guess I was busted but
yeah it was quite complicated and he
went wrong how is it to switch your mind
frame from a classical game to
Armageddon on such a short time in
between
um
I don't know I didn't really think uh
think much I just
I just thought I have to play a bit
faster especially since I was black I
was a just thinking I need to play first
and
um yeah that's basically what I what I
had planned
now you get a rest then you face Magnus
Carlson do you prepare any differently
for him than the other players
um let's see I I didn't really think
about the game yet but uh
um when I'm preparing I'll I'll make a
call
you've done well so far you're up there
in the top do you think that
that game or maybe match if it becomes
Armageddon against Magnus will Define
the your chance to win this tournament
oh it's uh I mean we are not put uh it
uh
at the half point of the tournament so
it's a long long shot
I mean playing Magnus is a fun game and
I'll try I'll trade it as a nice
uh as a game against the best player in
the world and I try to give my best and
and let's see what happens and we look
forward to seeing the best 17 year old
in the world playing against the best
player in the world thank you
giving us his thoughts on his crazy game
against Shakura mamajov in the
Armageddon and his thoughts on his next
encounter which of course will be
against Magnus Carlson it's you know
cash you know he's still 17 and this is
only his second time where he's been
playing on the world stage first of all
he played in tata Steels and now here he
is again butting heads with the world's
Elite
well I think he he takes it one at a
time and you can see when when he's
giving the interview her mod is his and
he's very careful what he says but it
was nice to listen that he said that we
are playing Magnus is gonna be fun
playing on his Elite tournaments of
course it's a real treat for for him
because he knows exactly that he's not
in his past yet it's his Rising Star so
from day to day when he's playing maybe
he's going to become you know every day
he's stronger and stronger and stronger
and he knows that this is just the
beginning the opportunities he's
receiving by being able to play here and
Judy you made your breakthrough into the
elite when you were a teenager as well
uh how did you find it and playing your
first kind of super tournaments your
first round robin events
oh that was quite some decades ago you
want me to remember those years
uh well it was it was very challenging
very challenging and
I don't know how much self-confidence I
had when let's say I played in 94 for
example on the first time in Linares
when you know that you're the underdog I
mean here go cash is not the same case
but when I played in that tournament it
was very clear that was the lowest rated
player so everybody was hunting me down
or wanted to uh challenges yeah that's
kind of the easiest game right
I think the most important thing is that
you really take it as a learning process
and even if something doesn't go your
way you you know that you have to learn
a lot of things until you can really
match with those guys and you shouldn't
be discouraged you have to take it as a
learning process at the same time
whenever they give a chance grab it
yeah I mean that type of healthy
attitude that clearly you had done I
mean good cash seems to have it now just
he said it learning experience just
enjoying the moment I mean that shows
just huge maturity I'm not sure I've
ever had that when I play the top
players I'm just shaking with me I'm
like okay just any results any means
possible and in the meantime we do have
a result between Wesley so and Denise
Geary that one has ended in a draw wow
sorry about interrupting you there David
no no this is far more important and
that means another Armageddon third of
the day three games so far have finished
and this one we thought was mostly in
the balance it lit up it kind of came to
life towards the end there briefly both
players now pointing towards the square
maybe just discussing uh one or two of
the key moments but a fair result dude
yeah I think it was pretty much of a
balanced game very quickly the queens
were off the board in this after the
opening and the blackhead isolated Pawn
but one weakness is not end of the world
but definitely not the end of the game
and the black played very active with
the bishop pair and the Knight on C6 and
then practically vastly did not see any
better than to centralize his Knight on
the center and then there was a
Liquidation in the game so it was
without too much of excitement this game
it was like little interesting strategic
and positional details but it was by far
not enough that even posing to unleash
race problems
yeah and uh looking forward to that
Armageddon game who do you hold as the
favorite can Wesley Shake It Up and win
with white this time on demand
I think Anish will be extremely tough
and he can play on their control
and let's face it I mean he's a very
stable player so to make a draw with
black is is I think easier for Anish
than a must-win situation with white so
for example against Wesley I think he
has much better chances to collect this
uh this point the match point with black
then if he would be playing with white
interesting enough both players have
actually had mixed Fortunes in the
Armageddon in the first round both of
them won Wesley defeated Hikaru in a
very Scrappy game that went right down
to the final seconds and then Gary was
just in complete control against Abdus
whereas in game in yesterday's round it
was a complete reverse like Wesley
seemed nervous towards the end and
[Laughter]
played against the Fabiano and he's also
extremely tough opponent and extremely
stable opponent and I think in this then
you can be extremely stable it's very
good to play with black because it means
that with white you have to provoke
things right because you play double or
nothing and for the character of uh Ani
somehow I feel and and for so that I
feel that it's easier to play for them
with black but maybe it's only my my
feel for that
yeah so we will delve into that
Armageddon game once it begins in
roughly 15 minutes time meanwhile we
haven't seen the game between Fabiano
caruana and ariantari for quite a while
now it has evolved and uh the position
that we see in front of us looks really
dangerous I've got to say for black with
Black's King an open H file nearby as
well and we just see a big decision on
the last move from Ariane to trade his
beautiful dark sky Bishop for one of the
white Knights so now the pawn structure
is a balanced for both of them and the
stakes high as well Judith what do you
make of this decision is it a scary for
black as it looks superficially well the
thing is that you know you like it or
not he wanted to save his Pawn on D5 so
it's it was I think a very concrete
decision that he thought that he wants
to save the pawn and also not only
saving the pawn but ruining white spawn
structure right so after Bishop C3 bc3 I
mean white has all these weaknesses on
A2 and C3
so the big question is how to defend and
save the pawn on D5 at the same time
being alert and paying attention that G4
Queen H3 for example can come in a
second right and suddenly there is a
huge threat on the H5 so black has to be
extremely careful watching out after
doubling on the H5 with the Rooks or
queen G4 Queen H3 or what I mentioned
before
uh G4 Queen H3 so those are the things
which he very much has to take care yeah
and also I just wanted to highlight
after G4 that there are ideas of maybe
even going the whole hog and sacrificing
everything like putting the Rook on H7
96 Queen takes up yeah beautiful Ivanka
let's bring up a board to show some of
the tactics in the uh the uh Greek
Creative Vision and that's definitely on
his radar if uh let's say Aryan plays a
random move let's say A6 G4 even if I
just play rookie five
I think you can go for it now right your
idea yeah boom Knight E6 check unless
I'm mistaken oh maybe I am mistaken even
though Knight takes G6 and maybe that
way yeah the problem might be the true
K5 at the end aha but we can show it all
the way yeah let's say just the idea if
if 96 rookie six let's say yeah black is
mistaken yeah you're right yeah Rook H7
so watch out for this theme to rise
check you trick the black king away you
take forcing the black king forward and
yeah at the end as you mentioned if the
Rook was on E5 maybe The Rook can block
but here this will walk into checkmate
uh so definitely in the air this type of
thing will recur from time to time and
Ariane has to watch out for it's a G4
big threat uh yeah
the D5 is the big threat so let's see if
Knight E7 Queen G5 here goes
not liked by the engine first question
is does white grab a pawn maybe there's
more ambitious uh options as well uh
second question is do we just go slowly
do we play a move like Rook H4 try to
swing the white Rooks across to the H
file to try to infiltrate later well I
would definitely pass through D5 first
it's a Capture wait one second a Euro
certified member of the porn grabbing
association yes
that was my first instinct as well
takes D5 yep it is possible
and evaluation bar doesn't move so
looks like a free porn and after root
takes D5 I don't think we want to trade
the Queens black would have good
compensation there uh but Knight takes
day five
yeah what's Ariana's idea I don't see it
I've got to say
95 is just a one move threat you can
just move the queen out of the way
happily
porn up maybe there was no idea to
Ariane he just was simply so afraid of
G4 G5 that he thought okay you know what
let me play this type of position I'm a
pawn down but
my pieces are active don't have to worry
about the king
yeah don't have to worry about the king
unless white goes for something else
maybe but I think maybe just two
tempting makes a lot of sense to just
grab a portal can we go back to root D5
Rook D5 Knight D5 Knight D5
and he went Queen E4 after that what
about Rook C4
uh I didn't spot that one whoops but
maybe you just go Queen F4 after all
yeah maybe in this position Queen F4
well you come back to C2 Queen G4
yeah I didn't want to retreat the queen
Rook C4 looks stronger on the other line
there so Queen takes Queen I guess we
take with this Pawn
or if you want to keep the queen then
you go Queen D1 or queen E2 instead of
F1
but I think this end game is very
difficult for black yeah actually maybe
you're right maybe Queen D1 is clever
just to kind of come to D4 later in some
circumstances F4 is threatened and you
can stabilize the D5 Knight playing E4
yeah I mean it's a torn up yeah
take it just uh I think that's what
Fabby after Queen F5 Rook H4 is a nice
move
to defend on the force full controller
yeah cover the E4 Square
yeah fortnite D3
oh I just realized there's something is
there some
night jump as well maybe Knight t7
ah
oh then I have to calculate but I don't
really you have to calculate we need
four F three Knight takes that three and
Knight F3 hitting this Knight
maybe we can just take the rook and get
away with it and there's no good
discover checks because the white king
can move but
yeah this is what Fabi might be thinking
about further down the line but right
now it is all about whether he takes
this Free Pawn in the center of the
board the other option looks like it's
doubling up Rooks on the H file
and this is the problem for uh the
player who is Underdog in a tournament
you know that
you lose a game like yesterday I already
lost in a very unfortunate way
uh next day you play
against Bobby and it can happen to you
again and and this is the most
frustrating in a very strong tournament
what happens if you are just not good
enough you even you can play pretty well
compared to your own level but simply
the others are stronger and uh it's it's
not easy to handle
and tomorrow it will be a free day
I mean how does one recover from a loss
before a free day because it can be a
good or a bad thing right you could have
that extra day to Stew on your mistakes
or you could have an extra day just to
forget about it what's your take on it
well chess players don't like to talk
about these things
what you do after a loss I I retired so
many years ago
but well I think in every tournament you
have different techniques because it
very much depends also how you lose the
game against who do you lose the game if
you know that you gave a great battle
and it was a very interesting game
then I'm not upset really I mean okay
it's a Pity I lost but my opponent was
better right but if you make unnecessary
mistakes for example it is extremely
annoying but what you have to do is that
try to forget what has happened until
that point think about points that is
there anything that you did very wrong
that you have to change or just go on
and make your preparation and the and
try to stay focused
that's the most important it's very
important not to lose your
self-confidence because if you start
drowning then of course it becomes more
and more difficult right but here for
example tari I mean he was a complete
living in yesterday he played a very
good game
unfortunately he ruined it not withdraw
but also to a loss but I'm also really
curious now how did you recover from a
painful loss because I've had certain
Grandmasters say that you know they
would go running
they pound the streets of the city as
fast as possible and
it depends I mean there were moments
when I was just crying then it was a big
walk but usually I was a good loser from
point of view that I got over like after
the game one hour passed and it's
already done you go dinner and then
you'll Focus for the next one
and and to you David yeah actually
um I'm on record as saying I hate rest
days as a player just because once the
momentum starts I just want to keep
going and going and going especially if
I'm doing well in a tournament rest days
are the worst you lose all your focus
you lose all your form and it's as if
you start a whole new tournament and
yeah it can be very much kind of a
momentum breaker but if things are going
badly rest day is great and in terms of
recovering from losses uh plus I'm not a
leading expert on that one I used to
struggle badly uh bouncing back from
losses emotionally and interesting
enough I think all the players are here
with their seconds
so what is the kind of the role of the
second aside from just preparing opening
moves obviously they spend a lot of time
together
what do you find the most helpful the
psychological aspect of chess tournament
is very important so of course it's
different when you have a coach who is a
coach of you generally speaking and
travels with you or you only have a
coach assisting you in the tournament
and for me it was when I was a kid I was
traveling with my parents my sister so
they were giving me this moral support
and they were cheering me up if
something went not so well but it was
always very good that there were people
around me who cared and they followed
very closely what was going on so they
knew exactly whether they can talk to me
or what or what to talk about or
something but for trainers actually I
did not have so many events where I had
coaches with me but my husband was also
traveling with me later on and he was
giving the support one of the most
important thing apart from getting good
material chest material and ideas after
the game you go for a walk you relax
they tell you stories or things like
that which cheers you up or it takes off
your mind from the problems or the the
things you're engaged with some did I do
this or that so somehow to loosening you
up and get into the mood of play and
excitement and positive attitude and
somehow find the balance so this
coaching part is very important for a
player yeah
certainly sounds important and David
have you ever been a second or had a
second with you yeah I've uh I've only
had a second with me once ever at the
tournament uh an English Grandmaster
Stephen Gordon and uh that was a
tournament in the Netherlands and I
remember I was having a tough time I was
uh I was quite young and I was playing
in a field with svidler gelfand uh some
very experienced players and they were
just crushing me and then uh yeah we
just went out one evening had a nice
dinner and uh he was like okay it's a
new tournament second half and I did far
better the second half it was all
psychological the opening prep barely
landed on the board unfortunately but uh
like you said it's a more kind of
emotional support and I think I'd lack
that throughout my career on the other
side I have been a second a few times
myself and I very much kind of enjoy
that kind of being there for the player
it's kind of a nice relief not to be
playing and to kind of pour all your
energy into the studying side into the
kind of uh psychological side and yeah
all the players you mentioned have been
doing that and we see Fabi in front of
us do you think Fabi is going to be
recording a podcast with his second here
he's here with uh Christian his uh
Christine carrilla well they they
recorded an art well not they it was
just Christian recorded analysis of game
one so that was quite instructive
and uh nothing came out for game two
I'll be watching Christian
uh we'll see I think so I think latest
after the tournament yeah latest I'll be
tuning into that one
Fabi with some really interest
interesting uh insights into his game so
I saw him at lunch today and he promised
to join us in the studio at some point
again this tournament okay yeah because
that means that he's winning the match
exactly maybe today yes okay so we look
forward to that and let's uh have a
revisit of the game between nordeback
and farouja because things were
promising to look quite Sharp
yeah this last move Judith just the
self-control the restraint it must uh
take from Fabi to retreat his Queen
preemptively uh interesting stuff
Queen E2 from Fabi just a quiet move and
the tension remains in that game
yeah it's interesting that he was not
taking actions
but the problem is the D5 Pawn is there
for a long time until it's not taken
I mean the weakness is there and he's
thinking maybe to go Queen B2
C4 long diagonal the position is
extremely difficult for black from
practical point of view I believe
yeah difficult stuff and meanwhile we
also see the other remaining classical
game in action with
deep in thought his opponent farrugia
alirezada away from the board we will
catch up on that one a bit later
definitely and because we do have an
Armageddon game starting in roughly
three minutes between Wesley so and
Anisha Gary
oh Wesley in a must-win situation and
let's remind ourselves of the Armageddon
format
black wins with a draw that's the most
important thing to know the players will
keep the same colors white will have 10
minutes black will have seven minutes
and one second will be added per move
only after the players have reached move
40. there's not much but it's a tiny
little thing to have some hope for and
then one and a half points for a win one
point for our loss the drama begins
trauma begins and we await those players
to take their seat to get going and uh
yeah I can't wait three armageddons I
have a feeling though that might be it
the two remaining classical games look
like uh looks like a decisive result
could be in store forestry well still I
think no deal breaker as a game might
end up in a draw because it happens
quite often and sometimes it's full of
fireworks and then the simplification
ends up in a drawish end game so there I
wouldn't give up our hopes
for another one and uh that's an
interesting point by eight bit Andy says
white is two nil in every Armageddon
game Wesley has paid this tournament
statistically impossible for giri to win
now
the numbers don't lie
facing basing predictions on a two-game
pool is uh not sure it's the biggest uh
statistical uh evidence to go on but
interesting yeah it's true Wesley one
with white lost yesterday with black in
his Armageddon games
so he needs a fast start here with white
he was slightly fortunate against Hikaru
Nakamura it should be said in the first
Armageddon of the tournament for Wesley
and yesterday for Anish it was not very
fortunate to play against Fabi right he
he got the reasonable opening but
somehow in the middle game Fabi was so
precise that Anish had no chance after
that it is round but now Anish seems to
be with full of confidence and I see
that Wesley a little bit nervous don't
you think so Wesley always looks
slightly tense and slightly nervous his
heart rate actually starts off usually
quite high but he did tell us once that
he feels very calm
even though his heart might be pounding
yeah everyone has their own way of
controlling their emotions Wesley won't
have too much time to get nervous and
it's a nimso Indian Judit it's a very
quick moves quick Exchange in the center
of the board blackheads Rock Solid we
could get that Carlsbad structure again
and what do you make of this start to
the game it feels well I would say
unabitious for white but it feels like
he's just trying to get the pieces out
uh get a position I like this position
with black I was playing it myself and I
I like this this kind of system for
black it's very active it's a very
healthy position of course white has his
ideas later on with F4
well now it's a strange structure
suddenly I wanted to say F3 and E4 but
suddenly we have Knight F4 exchanges on
F4 so F3 is not going to be part of it
unless we go forward to the end game and
F3 G4 comes but not for for some time
yeah interesting uh and very quick
decision that made there by Anish giri
to give up his Bishop pair to give up
his beautiful dot Squad Bishop the pride
and joy of any nimzoo player for white
tonight wrecking the white Pawn
structure but those double death pawns
can be a strength as well later in the
game now striking in the center
accelerating the play uh after giving
the opponent the bishop pair good
strategy there and
yeah what to do is Wesley difficult
decisions
first he improves defending the D4 Pawn
do you think Anisha is going to block
the center and the question is whether
or not G4 can be an idea here
um
but black is not developed so maybe
maybe a knight C6 kind of movement
developing pieces is better or what
you're saying C4 is always a temptation
but the question is but there's C4
Bishop C2 and then quick B3 will be
coming also Bishop A4 sometimes but C4
is on the board
C4 on the board white Retreats or will
Retreat imminently which direction
that's another question you can go the
other way potentially with the white
bishop and uh this is reminiscent of
that structure we were discussing
earlier in the orientatory game
pushing forward always comes with pros
and cons white has a very stable center
now but a niche quick to develop and we
can say that the players are practically
playing based on their intuition because
they're just flashing out the move right
so they were not spending much time at
all
and uh like they are really playing it
as a Blitz game and we can say it it's
not completely a Blitz game because
nowadays Blitz game is 3 minutes and two
seconds and here they have much more
time than that
is like an ocean of time having 10
minutes to start the game with white but
I think it's very difficult to switch if
you would be switching to Blitz
it would be much easier because then you
know it's only your hand and intuition
right but when it's 10 minutes versus
seven it is very tricky because if you
get a lost position then then you're not
going to play for time or so on I mean
now eight minutes for for Wesley and
five and a half for an age but the
position is pretty balanced so he wants
to go very much B5 and it was a very
nice idea I think provoking A3 because
already now B3 is not the same if he's
going to be playing it and how is white
gonna Liberate the two Bishops um F3 and
drop it back to F2 earlier than expected
thank you Wesley for answering yeah he
wants to drop this bishop back and F3 is
a multi-purpose move this Pawn on F3
controls at least for now this Black
Knight on F6 and watch out later in the
game when he's ready when the white king
is secure he might even start throwing
pawns forward on the king side using G4
and G4 has been a theme of the
tournament so far uh look at wow
anishikiri is standing up to check the
number of moves they've made it's only
move 17 and ish you still have a long
way to go before you get that desired
increment wow okay I said maybe later in
the game he's played it instantly of
course of course what to wait for
to develop the pieces is what I thought
uh Bishop on B1 what do you want to do
exactly
develop it well I don't know but it's
you know
Bishop F2 yeah Bishop is getting ready
to re-route itself the G3 or H4 H4 right
or just for the moment to exchange the
Rook is also relieving the position
a little bit
and black can advance all he wants Anish
does so pushing to B4 but he's only
opening up the white Rook on A1 and I
don't think necessarily Wesley Mainz
retreating the white knight in the next
few moves first he's modeling over
whether to trade off a set of Rooks to
take or not to take Judith or do we just
uh Retreat now well the tension is there
again as in so many games I would go
Knight A4 I think but he takes on E8
first and now question whether Knight E2
or A4 and C5
taking this Pawn would you be trying to
open up the white Rook or
would he just keep the tension I'm
surprised Wesley is even hesitating I
think I'd be too tempted to take it to
capture right now
and that's that's a downside maybe black
doesn't take back with a pawn makes a
lot of sense The Rook on A1 isn't
working
take it no hesitation from me yeah but
in case you take and you go let's say
Knight E2 then black and gold Bishop D7
and exchange on A8 and I'm not sure you
want to exchange the Rooks from White's
perspective is maybe you were trying to
dream still that one day it comes out
from A1 to E1 or something well Wesley
agrees with you Knight is on E2 and when
it comes to the clock situation well a
niche under five minutes
and uh wow one takes porn looks very bad
for white I must say Rook B3 he's
entering the black piece is pouring in
and you can definitely tell this is
Armageddon you'll move on the board
there Judith you can tell the risks are
being taken by Wesley in this must win
situation he's imbalanced it he's got
the bishop pair he's got this weird
looking Pawn structure and imbalances to
help your winning chances but they do
come at the cost of these massive risks
if the opponent gets active and look at
that Rook so at the same time white can
go King G2 Knight G3 Bishop C2 finally
out of from B1 and then the A1 Rook is
rescued wow F5 I like this move I mean
okay the computer
disagrees and awards it a question mark
but uh for me very nice practical choice
now I think there is a great opportunity
for white to put this on C3 the night I
don't know if now it's possible but for
sure it's going to be there and it's a
very nice location for the Knight on C3
maybe after Queen C1 but now it's can
you even think about sacrificing like
Brooke takes bishop and then take oh
that's on the board okay it's done
because that Bishop was uh becoming
dangerous
yeah not too much risk involved despite
the material deficit now here for black
because you get all the light squares
you've anchored that's your idea and
that's an issue's idea really
instructive stuff Black's light squared
Bishop could be the most valuable piece
very shortly White's King to put on
structure King side portrait structure
that is just wrecked and The Bishop's
coming out it looks so easy to play for
black but uh you still have to make sure
that the Queen stay on the board the
white Brook doesn't get active first
what to do with this bishop but still
the players have five minutes for Wesley
and four minutes for our nation they are
playing it as if if they would both have
minute left or something
yeah but I I think for Wesley that's
probably a wise decision to kind of like
speed up the place pace and just play
those natural moves because
his only chance in actually winning this
is just to initiate Chaos on the board
and to confuse a niche
yeah it definitely feels like Anish
hasn't been confused so far it just
feels like he's in the zone this last
night move really really classy uh White
really doesn't want to go and take this
ball now because there'll be a nasty hit
uh bump from the bishop the black Bishop
would have come to F5 hit the White
Queen while the players are moving so
fast barely keeping up here and uh okay
all the pieces on Dart squares now all
of White's pieces most of the pawns on
dark squares away from the color complex
of the black Bishop watch out for this
D5 Pawn is under threat welcome I think
it was smart from Wesley to put the King
on H2 on black Square just in case that
the bishop will not cause any unpleasant
tactics
and uh he's lucky here any hit okay any
hits I was gonna say on the H3 Pawn can
be defended by White's Queen it could
have been defended from E3 but that's
where it's taken away from anishagiri
but this uh last move from the Pawn on
D5 you wanna see
sorry yes absolutely and we see it there
from Wesley because I mean Black's lost
the whole tactical point was that you
couldn't take this Pawn because the
queen would step forward to F5 yes
yeah do you think Gary missed or
underestimated this move because you saw
how nervous he was he stood up to look
at the screen to see the move number and
uh still kind of he's got enough time he
doesn't need to think about the
increment yet suddenly the Black Knight
The Black Queen forces the White Knight
back but the material count now is a
pure exchange Rook for night that's too
much for Gary he's coming in with the
Knights though big threat reader it's
not helping black to open up the
position I must say unless Bishop C6
Knight F3 is really showing up on the on
the board but probably Bishop D4 and now
Queen F2 Queen a e3 trade Queen history
what is this Knight C2 Knight C2 oh wow
has he just blundered into a fork he has
oops Knights are so tricky and Blitz in
speed chess not only in Blitz trust me
in general dudette Knights are the
trickiest beasts you will ever find and
simple material lost and black is
winning wow he was just starting to work
his magic Wesley so that white had
opened up the position he had the
material advantage he had the rook and
suddenly is this just game over yeah and
uh you can see it there from Wesley he
knows it is over and
just simply making those moves because
the alternative just to resign the game
what a blunder from Wesley so and now
he's trying to counter-attack the sneak
attack here using his Knight to hit the
black queen but the black queen as long
as she finds a safe Square I've been C6
let's say exactly the simplest the fork
remains Queen C6 looks like game over
the White Queen I don't see any squares
she can use to get behind to get at that
black king is that to me it doesn't look
like black can go wrong
maybe there's one or two squares where
you have to be a bit careful but yeah
Queen E6 Queen C6 Queen
queen queen G6
so this is what I'm saying when you lose
in a in a in a way that you blunder
heavily those losses are much more
difficult to digest yeah Queen C6 on the
board
ah he's human Wesley so he's one of us
as we saw in the featured chat there and
suddenly what to do how do you pick
apart the ruins of your position it
might be just simply too late too little
too late here the White Queen White Rook
attacked White's night vulnerable as
well I love this just if in doubt in
Blitz put your pieces on squares they're
protected like anisha's just done with
his Queen
nice strategy there nice Blitz tip for
everyone and
finally Wesley had a good position and
probably he was already better
that's when he blundered and the gamer
goes on and he's gambling here he's
trying to get behind with the White
Queen but it's just uh not enough here
I think you can just take that Rook it's
also tempting to capture the Knight
but I agree capture The Rook keep it
simple and he goes for it
with his check do you block it you can
block it with your queen with your
Bishop you can even run with the King
potentially
I like Queen C8 simple just
though everything is winning I believe
and he does do that and Anish has all
the time in the world he has over one
minute to find the way to put this point
in the bag and you can tell on the body
language there on the camera Wesley
doesn't really believe in his chances
otherwise he would be hunched over the
board making quick moves he just gives a
spike check there but anisha's blocking
everything
yeah just beautiful technique from Anish
there and he's going to try and repeat
moves Force the draw a draw is the same
as a win for black and a smile from
Anish Gary he takes the draw and this
match
yeah this this is a nice gesture I must
say
okay I I understand that the point is
collected but still at least he
the game is a draw professional the
professional approach do the minimum
possible that's yeah the final position
probably winning for black but he didn't
want to take any risk no but also you're
not uh so proud of yourself to win the
game like that the top level blundering
group right so you have kind of a bad
feeling for the other one you're
collecting the point don't misunderstand
me but you're not so eager necessarily
to win win the game
yeah
and uh the we see the players leave the
hall and well another game that has been
decided by Armageddon
and still two classical games remaining
and it's worth pointing out all of the
Armageddon games were won in Black's
favor so far today uh just it's a black
day and will that Trend continue you
mentioned two games remaining Ivanka two
dramatic games where shall we go first
I think I'll let Judith decide go ahead
no we have to go for both but I'm afraid
that we should be going to Fabiano sorry
because that's uh
there's a peace and balance maybe it's
going to be not so long
yeah this one could be over in the near
future let's jump in you can see again
body language Fabi extremely focused
Ariane does not look happy at all with
what has happened what has transpired
over the last few moves and peace and
balance the queen for two Rooks white
has the two Rooks white has the safer
King this Pawn on F6 a real thorn in
Black side closing the cage around the
black king there must be some check
mating ideas
let's hear somewhere I don't see it yet
but it feels that way any Rook on the
back rank now if you could teleport one
of the white Rooks up to A8 or on the
back rank this would end in Checkmate
isn't Rook H1 a possibility right now
Queen takes Knight F3
and wow just like that
okay he's played C4 also winning holding
on to the White Knight
yeah I think we'll jump in and show that
one shooter maybe that was an immediate
knockout that would have been lights out
for Aryan tari
okay
well we should probably let the players
figure it out here because it's time to
take a quick break we've had a lot of
excitement and let's catch our breaths
for the moment as we see Fabiana
Carolina and Ariana Just
Slug It Out you're in for treat catch
you on the other side
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the bow Test
sisters come on look at this
the chess.com Community streamer program
is growing every day
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
[Music]
foreign
here in Norway chess and I'm your host
ivank houska and I am here with the
woman who beat Gary Kasparov Judith
Polgar and the man that got his
autograph once David Howell
oh you got me again Ivanka
only for today only for I promise last
one that's true I do have Gary's
autograph
and there's no we've had an incredible
day of fun it's been a lot of excitement
a lot of action and talking about action
we actually had a result during the
break as we saw Fabiana caruana he's
just in dominant form and he took down
orientare as expected what a game by
Fabi yeah just before the break we were
at this game and we thought oh there's
too many checkmating patterns against
that black king and he found one
yeah absolutely it was uh I think it was
a pretty convincing Victory by uh Fabi
we can say so because after the opening
already when Magnus visited the studio
he also said that it looks uh pretty
dangerous for black because black
castled before time and it meant that
the Fabi was ready for attack without
castling himself on a later stage he put
his King into safety and somehow there
were too many witnesses and dangers in
the black camps and the Atari somehow
got lost there and we shouldn't forget
of course that Fabi is one of the top
players in the world and the most
experienced so once you give a chance to
a player like Fabiano
he is most likely not going to let it go
yeah Fabiano's two classical wins in the
tournament one Armageddon win as well he
is the breakout leader after round three
of Norway chess and we see the players
still analyzing let's jump in to show
the closing stages of that game and uh
maybe a couple of the highlights on how
Fabi closed out that Victory it was in
uh this position that we left it a bit
earlier we saw the uh kind of imbalance
of Queen for Rooks a bit later on but
let's see how we got there Queen to E7 I
think it's very important to to mark
this point because we wanted to take on
D5 and sometimes it's better just to
keep the tension and attack the pawn
right than to take it and queen E2 was
an interesting point here that it's not
even that he wants to take it he doesn't
want to attack it he just comes back and
has a completely other mentality to
convert the advantage yeah you're
completely right there Judith beautiful
control no rush the idea is maybe in
this variation uh kind of coming from
this angle at least against the black
talking in some circumstances black
retreated we see here from the graphic a
double question mark move this
potentially the game changing blunder
but it was already difficult for black
from Human terms it may be impossible to
defend the black king simply too much of
a Target Knight takes D5 simply winning
a pawn if uh if the queen had dropped
down to E4 then this check would have
been blocked by F3 instead Ariane gave
uh what gave his best shot Queen E6 E4
and after the Rooks that across
utilizing the pin on the e-file white
simply played rookie one Queen C8 and
this was the moment the imbalance began
e takes F5 and maybe the detail that was
missed by Ariane instead of Rook takes
E2 recovering the material white first
flicked in the devastating F6 check and
his visionzuk and Intermezzo there
intermediate move and we saw this
position and Judith spotted a beautiful
win in this position after Queen F5 Rook
H1 would have ended the game on the spot
this Checkmate is almost Unstoppable you
can even afford to give up the Knight
for free white just blocks if King tries
to cover h8 this would have ended in
Checkmate as well instead Fabi found an
equally efficient way port to C4
defending the Knight threatening Rook to
H1 and after Knight to E5 he simply
doubled up one of the Rooks is breaking
through now to E8 to make the black king
uh one last check and White's King safe
the Black Knight falling and Checkmate
imminent beautiful and brutal finish
really impressive game from Fabi he
seems to be on fire really on form and
I'm just saying that from all of his
games right I mean yesterday we we saw
him in the classical game get the upper
hand over a niche and then in the
Armageddon he just
I know it's like a running joke but it
really did feel like he got his
preparation in knew exactly what to do
to neutralize white and one felt very
smoothly yeah so far he's playing in
incredible stability that's very clear
and so far so great for him but
something strange happening yeah should
we dive immediately crazy tactics are
going on with another back of the
satirov
yeah the remaining game is a corker and
it's a stunner we jumped in at the right
moments and uh we earlier talked about
how fruition was turning things around
he'd exploded things open only in
Black's favor partly because of those
stranded White Knight on A4 and look at
this double X Glam double exclamation
point there and he's just giving off the
white uh giving up the black queen this
is beautiful beautiful Checkmate pattern
genius let's show this on the board we
have to show what's just happened Knight
takes F2 the black queen can simply be
captured but this would end immediately
in Checkmate uh I don't know if I've
seen this pattern before happen in a
game Rook takes Queen in this position
would allow the beautiful Knight H1 H3
H3 that's H3 even whoops H3 what am I
talking about Knight H3 even better and
Checkmate next move uh well Queen F2 you
can just take this piece and you're
trapped
beautiful stuff let's just recap maybe
the last few moves uh in this position
uh we saw just a few moves back it was
still crazy Rook takes F5 Queen takes A3
F uh quintix E3 Queen D7 and it was here
that uh blunder did occur missing this
beautiful tactic Rook C to D1 from Abdul
satorov in a defensible position missing
Knight takes F2 the killer blue
Citrus game over nothing to do you can
trade Rooks but black will just take
back and
well he has to sacrifice the queen right
enough to
F2 the only way to keep the game
fighting but black will be up material
and he will be keeping on fighting
yeah and that will be quite a long game
still I believe for a while but yeah
decisive material advantage for black
let's just put that one on the board and
Rooker Knight versus queen unfortunately
black has a majority on the king side
and this Knight so far off side
looks like yeah farouza has woken up
after day one after struggling on the
board on the clock in the first game of
the tournament against kukash two
classical wins in a row potentially
wow I have to say a beautiful game by
alireza farouza you know he knew when to
initiate all the action and I'm just
impressed by how he's handled this and
yep they get the position that you have
on the board oh no that was it's gonna
happen I mean it's the only way to stay
alive and there we can see from the
looks on an order back's face he knows
it he is in big big trouble
getting ready to pounce and
win his second
classical game
and uh meanwhile
we are joined in the studio by a very
special guest Fabiana caruana who just
played a very impressive game against
orientare
are you also enjoying Ali Reza's play
there yeah it's I didn't really see most
of the game
but uh the final attack is really
beautiful
yeah it's uh I mean after a tough start
he's really recovering very well
and uh talk us through your game today
you're making the games look easy
yeah it was well I played an ambitious
one basically C takes D5 trying to is
just an attempt to keep the game going
as long as possible and it avoids this
terrorist line that Anish played today
which is basically killing uh killing
chess so the only way to avoid is you
take on D5 and and you get an equal
position but a one which you can play
for a very long time
and he wasn't super familiar with it
it's actually magnus's um one of
magnus's pet lines he played it even
here a few years ago against against
Levon aronian and it was sort of his
idea that you uh you play Queen C2 and
then you trade lights were Bishops it
looks like black is achieving everything
that he wants
but uh there are still some problems and
and I have this kind of because my king
is in the center I have the possibility
to push the H Pawn
and yeah it uh he wasn't familiar with
it he didn't play very well I think with
Knight A6 C5 it feels like the wrong
direction
and it was just a very very pleasant
safe position I never had any risk
um it was just a question of if he's
going to equalize or if I can actually
prove an advantage
did you ever feel like your advantage
was slipping away in the game or was
it wasn't troll I wasn't sure I thought
I might not be playing Super accurately
because there were many moments when I
could play this king of one G3 King G2
or I could play A3 or dz5 or Force
things
but I I didn't see clearly if forcing
things would lead to an advantage and uh
the one moment I was really not sure
about was when he played rookie five I
played this Knight d2 move I was really
tempted by other options uh especially
one which was really beautiful and I
really wanted to make it work but it was
it took every every bit of my uh
self-control not to play it it was the
movie E4 after um after rookie five and
I thought maybe this is just winning on
the spot
but uh
yeah
thank you
we'll bring it we'll bring it up
[Laughter]
and uh yeah
I don't and uh
yeah and I say E5 and what made you not
choose that move
oh it was really really sharp and it
just
oh no it was it was before this so so
this moment the game was already over I
thought but after rookie five I had a
very very
a big choice and I played yeah like okay
Knight D2 it's it's probably a safe
option but E4 is very tempting
it looks like it can't possibly work
um and then but then it looked like it's
working but then I saw he has DTX E4
Knight takes E4 and Rook takes E4
and I think Rook 64 is the only move
Knight C6 and queen E8
and it's very important that after I
play Rook H7
King H7 Queen F6 he has rookie one
and he saves the game like this wow I
don't see any other way for him to
defend against Rook H1 Rook takes E1 and
queen C6 maybe Queen E1 is also a drop
of Queen c6s
um
although actually Queen C6 maybe the
working game is not super Pleasant I
don't know but uh but but Queenie one as
well and so I was really tempted to play
as E4 and then I restrained myself I
played Knight E2 and it worked out yeah
yeah it was the impressive piece of
calculation there Favi but uh yeah so uh
there was a later stage when I was
wondering or we were discussing you
regrouped your knight to F4 and when you
did not capture the pawn on D5 but you
went Queen E2 what was the thought
behind it that you wanted to torture
even longer well no I so
my okay the first thing I looked at was
Rook T5 but then I I didn't want to play
an end game because I thought it could
be rather uh like rookie five Queen if I
didn't want to go for and Rook D5 Knight
D5 I thought he has 95. and uh
yeah I just didn't I thought I thought
maybe his work goes to C4 and active
um yeah I wasn't 100 sure about this
although it I do have this thread of f4
I didn't actually realize so so maybe
it's very strong
um
and so yeah maybe this was good but I
thought Queenie too like I didn't see a
move for him
uh because I'm going to the B2 square
and I'm going to maybe play C4 and it's
kind of
um trying to maximize the position I
guess not not even being satisfied with
just upon and I I was expecting Rook h8
here because I thought
I also have this idea of Rook H4 and
Rook H1 and if I double my Rooks at any
point he just gets checkmated
so whenever I play Rook H4 he'll have to
to play Rook h8
but I thought if 4K shade I take I play
Queen B2 I'll I'll collect some pawns
like he's not going to keep his
um his deep on
uh yeah Queen B2 and so you believe that
you will be able to capture it in a much
better circumstance that's what I
thought I I could have been it could
have been a mistake but that's that was
my feeling
and
were you because that obviously took
some willpower actually not to accept
that pawn were you quite proud of your
decision to resist the lure of material
no I don't know what it is but I I never
want to take whenever there's a pawn I
feel like it's a trap I feel like I I
shouldn't be capturing this this Free
Pawn so my first instinct was actually
either Queenie 2 or Rook H4 like these
are the first two moves that felt right
like something for some reason I didn't
want to take on D5 maybe it's also
a believer of a threat is more painful
or dangerous than the execution I think
I think that's usually the case yeah and
and especially
like I had this feeling that The Rook on
F5 is just so awkwardly placed it it
feels like I might be able to actually
win more material than just the than
just the d-pawn
and two words the end we were seeing
when you played C4
were you not considering to win video
yeah yeah no but I thought okay Rook H1
I'll be an exchange up and it's not
enough he'll be he'll play on for a few
more moves okay C4 is just checkmate
of winning right it was I it was 50 50.
I was also like I was thinking okay Rook
H1 is kind of the professional way let's
say but C4 uh C4 felt like the right way
C4 is saving energy right
well I don't I think he would resign
anyway after work H1 because it's it's
really I mean it's not an exchange up
where you can really play on too much
but uh but yeah everything wins here it
feels like
and uh Fabi you've had a great start to
the tournament you know you beat Magnus
Carlson a classical game yesterday you
beat Anish Gary in a wonderful
Armageddon game I mean what are you
doing I mean what do you do what is your
routine
I I'm not doing anything special
um but I actually quite like the late
games it it feels like it gives you a
more relaxed morning I play a lot of
events especially in like St Louis where
the game start very often at one o'clock
and it just feels like a rush to get to
the game to prep you know you you have
to let's say prepare for Wesley and try
to find something to do against the
Berlin or or whatever Wesley's playing
and and you have like like an hour to do
so here it's it's relaxed you can you
can take your time thinking about what
you want to play I also like that even
if it's a draw uh use it doesn't feel
like a disappointing day because you
still have something to play for uh
while very often very often there's this
anti-climax if you're
if you're making a short draw or an
uneventful draw and and you feel like
okay I just wasted the whole day but I
quite like the Armageddon format
although I I like to watch the
Armageddon other other Armageddon too
it's like some extra entertainment
during the round
it certainly is and uh we're going to go
back to the Nordic Abdus tour of alireza
fuja game uh is the any hope for norda
back in this position
I guess some
uh
so where's he so he'll take on P3
I don't know if he'll be I mean queen Z2
rookie two I don't see that how how
black can get more than just taking on
B3 and I guess why puts the Knight
on F3 or where where are you putting it
on F2 Maybe
you can put an E3 D1 F2 but Plex pawns
will start to run
um
not too much hope especially with the
time Patrol
and what do you think of the time
control actually with no increment and
when you do get increment it's after me
40 and it then it's only 10 seconds it's
pretty brutal you don't want to get into
time trouble
I you know I think we played with the
same time control in 2019
and I was playing against Ding and I got
a bad position of the opening
and at some point I'm like
close to defending but I have to play
long end game with 10 seconds and he has
all the time in the world I have 10
seconds for the rest of the game I mean
every move I can only think for like for
10 seconds and it was an impossible task
at some point I made a mistake even
though objectively I had to draw at some
moment so if you get into time trouble
especially in a bad position it's just
brutal
totally brutal but are you in favor in
general if there's no increment
well there should be some increment I I
don't think that game should end in
let's say dead drawing positions with
someone flagging maybe in Blitz you can
have that but in a classical game you
don't want to see some Rook against rook
and someone Flags it just doesn't feel
like a fair end to the game so 10
seconds is is basically bare minimum I
think I think this is pretty much the
fastest control that uh
let's say unless you want to play some
kind of mix between rapid and classical
like let's say an hour long game or a 45
minute game
but uh but this is a really really fast
time control yeah don't you get confused
that in the first 40 moves you don't get
any bonus time and it starts from move
41.
yeah it's I'm kind of used to it I mean
we've we play with all sorts of time
controls all the time it's always
there's no like uniform time control uh
even in even in like official fide
events which I always thought was
strange that they they don't have let's
say one uniform time control it's always
changing from event to event even in
like the world championship cycle
sometimes it changes within the cycle
which is very strange so so I have a lot
of experience with different time
controls uh with no increment before
move 40 with no increment even at all
um
I think you you sort of know what you
have to do like what
what do you have to avoid let's say and
here getting into time trouble is
something that you should generally
avoid is it something that you prepare
specifically to train your mindset that
you how to switch from one tournament to
another for different time controls I
don't know if there is a way to prepare
like you get into a groove of it during
the event but uh like you're not going
to play training games with two hours
training games no but I thought that the
before the tournament you make a
strategy that in the opening you make
your moves in a certain amount of time
you know you force yourself to make
decisions in certain moments if you go
down to 10 minutes then you go for the
safer direction or things like that I
think definitely in terms of opening
choices like you're you're searching for
openings where you're not going to
um
where you don't have to make decisions
that will drain all your time or where
the cost of a mistake isn't so high that
that if you let's say are are in a bit
of a Time Rush that that you uh that you
can't afford to make a single mistake so
definitely opening choices like today's
opening I I played one where you can
kind of go on autopilot a little bit
especially if you know some of the plans
uh you're like I know that my first few
decisions in the game aren't going to be
super super
um
High responsibility let's say uh
like the days that you probably remember
well where like the night or with uh
Bishop E3 E6 G4 I don't think those
openings are going to be played in this
tournament
um
like some yeah I think we see a bit more
pragmatic chess and especially with
opening choices here and what about the
Armageddon we see that some players are
playing very fast let's say for example
Anish against you yesterday he was just
flashing out and you had the feeling
that he really is in the mood to play
like if it would be a three minute game
like the first day the blitz tournament
and like after making a lot of moves and
maybe getting in trouble or at some
point
I have the feeling that he should have
been thinking earlier maybe before
making some decisions how difficult it
is to switch what is the best thing
because it's only 15 minutes for the
players right so how difficult it is to
really switch and get into the new
mindset depending whether you play with
white and you have a mastering situation
with 10 minutes versus 7 minutes into
your back black yeah I think the
Armageddon time management is so
difficult and I I feel like I've gotten
a bit like with some experience
especially especially in the Champions
just where I constantly playing
Armageddon uh with some experience I've
started to kind of get a better feeling
of where like you need to take your time
although I I remember I was playing the
the final
um in the Champions Oregon sikaru and
and in the final Armageddon game so
whoever wins this is going to win the
the uh that leg of the tour and I got a
winning position and I was up
uh time as well and when I look back on
it I ended up losing the game when I
looked back on it like the critical
moment where I didn't where I decided to
not take time I'm like this is so
obvious like this is the moment when you
take time but in the when you're in the
heat of it you you don't realize
um or maybe this is the skill that you
need like to to realize it might almost
be
like a subconscious thing like a feeling
of where you need to think
um so sometimes you
sometimes you fail just see that I got
distracted because it says that this
King F6 is a mistake
I think it's just a missed opportunity
but uh not necessarily a mistake maybe
there was a more direct win maybe G4
there's no need to rush right can I play
G4
well after G4 F4 is it that drill right
rookie two
and what is not not enough space but but
maybe to take on G4 and queen B4 and
somehow the G4 Pawn is going to be
vulnerable yeah I'm wondering because we
have maybe some counter playwright
against like Rook H1
contemplate
[Laughter]
play yeah I guess I have to wait with
Rook G1 can you can you break this down
Queen on F4 and then H5 at some moment
but
yeah I think some somehow it will be
tied up
maybe I would give check first sorry I
give queen bee to check first instead of
Queen B4
but then King G3 Queen beef
King ear King B4 Queen B4 so you go to
G1 right
uh
yeah like it is close to like Rook F1
could almost be close if I get like
Knight on H2 Rook F3 and
and just in the meantime there's a quick
question from chap says Fabi who are you
looking forward to playing the most in
the rest of the tournament uh
you got a Magnus out of the way maybe
Ali Reza he's always very interesting to
play against he's one of the
most combative players I mean you always
see he's he's going forward with against
anyone with both colors uh he plays a
very specific brand of Chess and also
he's uh he wins this let's say then he's
doing very well in the tournament so uh
so he'll definitely be one to look out
for
and is there any chest style that you
dread facing oh is that too personal
style that where they play really good
moves for a long time
that's that's a good answer
G4 is on the board by the way and uh we
have another also another question from
Chad said what was your favorite video
game growing up
I don't know my favorite but I remember
my first video game was uh was Legend of
Zelda The Wind Waker oh
it's just been released yeah there's a
new Zelda game right I
for my nephew I I uh for Christmas I
bought him the previous ldm what was it
I forget the name of it and I don't know
um I mean always a fan of Zelda but um
I don't know I I I wouldn't say I maybe
like Ratchet and Clank I played those
games those were some of my favorites
when I was a kid
not Super Mario
um
yeah some of the games I I enjoyed I
mean it's like side scrollers were not
let's say my favorite type of game but
yeah I've ever I mean obviously it's a
it's a classic right
and
the queen gives a check no I have to
confess I I actually didn't play any
video games I just played chess and I
think the only thing I had was like
chess master
2000 yeah
and I thought that was so cool
yeah do you think of the center of can
save the game with 56 seconds on the
clock and this position
probably not
maybe black doesn't even take on G4 yeah
maybe now could be enough for also H5 is
really tempting right I thought could be
enough for enough said that and then H5
yeah yeah also
yeah it feels like this is falling apart
Dan White's defenses
because I think maybe queen of four gf5
looks like the move and then H5
and how is white
um
but there may be rookie six checking F5
oh rookie Five Oh I thought rookie five
yeah yeah rookie five
wait did he play H5 or this is the okay
yeah this would be a beautiful trick
maybe rookie8 as well is also is also
holding it there
because somehow the Knight is holding
it's so well controls all the important
squares actually the queen of four
okay why don't we try H5 immediately
let's see I mean it might just win by
force right
GTX F5 yeah G4 so you have to take take
a knight E6 oh
now but can you not do the same trick
again
oh
okay so H5 great great move let me
yeah
Queen C5
yeah yeah
that's that's still an option
maybe there's something really
clinical here
wait what if Queen C5 check where are
you hiding
G2 the queen C2 how you have no nowhere
to go you have to go to F1 it's very
very sad oh then take send me C4 you
grabbed it yeah
so I actually have to Queen C5 do you
have any move not to resign
like King King G3 maybe in G3
but you know after Queen g king G3 H5
can be now the move or queen F2 GF H5
you could also Quincy Southern Queen C2
I think that you have an abundance of
choice here yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and uh what pitfalls are there for black
like for instance people might be saying
well you could well we should we showed
one and uh what about taking oh yeah
this is very good also because Rook G1
H5 is
but what do you mean H5 takes G4 Rook G3
and King B7 we are somewhere and then
agree to win against trick
uh but queen against Rook is hopeless I
was always amazed when when people
like somehow survive queen against
workouts like it feels like I would
I'd be attempted to resign at the very
beginning but there have been some cases
where people survived like uh
girlfriend's feeder was this yes this
was a game yeah but I've I've been told
that it's actually not that easy queen
against Rook if you hold the third row
yeah and if you play it against the
computer you have the queen like most
more often than not it will draw it once
it's actually very tough yeah yeah
against a computer but
but uh we're not computers
and I have an interesting start for you
all so if ferrugia converts this
position against Abdul sotorov his 2023
performance of just 12 games will be
2806 with nine decisive games and just
three draws
very impressive right that's a good
performance yeah
King G2
King G2 oh that's tricky H4 King F2
but uh okay he played it yeah
but wait is HG but after age
you're playing it on E1 or
H2 but H2 G3
Knight F3 G4
um
nut is gonna kick throughout I mean
tonight is a pretty sad
horse
[Laughter]
so if Knight E1 Queen E3
Rook F1 yeah then Queen H3 followed by
G3
and Knight F3 G4 or yeah or G4 G2
and
update not much time left you think it's
time to extend the hand
but they're shooting play H4 or grabbed
the pawn this is what he's has it they
think
I think yeah grabbing is that's
practical and grabbed it
and queen E3 that feels like
so Queen E3 King F1
can you go G3 and rojita and then just
bring King in
yeah it doesn't feel like it's gonna I
don't need one
no wriggling
oh you probably have to but
wait can you
G3 immediately is not as good right
because Rook F1
Queen H4 Knight F3
that's maybe even saving yeah that's
that's already a bit
big mistake
maybe Queen E4 check
after king of what does it change things
I know
so if we need three Rook F1 yeah
three King F1 yeah
but I think G3 Rook G2 and bringing the
king up uh
laughs
I'm sorry I just I was laughing at that
chat
um
no but this was uh when I was doing a
commentary with Danny and Robert in 2021
this was the uh
they at some point Danny wanted to do a
skip we didn't have time for it because
the match ended prematurely but the the
skit was uh that I was being held
hostage
and I I finally Escape
and um have you seen Shawshank
Redemption no but uh David has yes the
the final and then finally I like
I crawl through they're somehow gonna
set this up I don't know how but I crawl
through something and then I I like
emerge on the other side like I finally
won my freedom this was this was idea it
never actually happened
but now we need to and it's yeah yeah
Google Play Queen F2
as well
queen of two is stylish H1
and then then what
I want the queen queen A2 and Rook H1
look at the queen of two you can play G4
and G2 and then you don't you win The
Rook in the end as well
sure
so it helps the tactics for breakfast
not lunch not dinner
and oh there we go there we go and there
we have a result
alireza playing a magnificent game to
win with the black pieces in the
classical portion against Nordic Abdus
Turf and thus walking away with three
points oh it's been a remarkable day and
Fabi thank you so much for joining us in
the comments and thank you for all your
insights and keep on playing Amazing
chess congratulations thanks
and oh
wow that means we have to look at
today's scores what a day of chess
for Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus Carlson
it was a short battle but it was Magnus
Carlson that walked away with that extra
half point in the Armageddon game and
some decisive victories in the classical
games for alireza farouza who just
defeated nordebec Abdul soturf and also
Fabiano carono who played a very
impressive game to overwhelm ariantari
what results really make an impression
on you Judith
there were so many things happening
today also I'm in my major of the
playoff it was it was a disappointment
for Mama jarova I mean he had such a
beautiful game after an opening but go
cash was strong and he was hanging on
and made some very tough uh tough moves
and but well which game I mean Fabi made
a very beautiful game he was very
convincing and very nicely developed his
advantage and went through real
professional job and for you David yeah
mean Fabi stood out I've got to say
alireza just how he worked his magic to
strike with black to create something
out of nothing and then to finish it off
in real style there uh yeah just
extremely impressive we were treated
though we started off on such a high
note with that King's Gambit in the
Armageddon between Hikaru and Magnus it
feels like days ago at this point but
that was the uh yeah that was the game
that really kind of lit the fire uh for
today and so many more decisive results
the format keeps paying off I know it
does and uh let's take a look at the
standings after all that action on the
board and in the early lead is Fabiana
Corona with a magnificent seven and a
half points out of nine second place
alireza farouza with two classical wins
in a row then we have Hikaru Nakamura on
Five Points and still in the bottom half
we have Wesley so and Magnus Carlson
three and a half points and three point
I said they will need to be winning some
classical games
oh and let's take a look at Saturday's
matchups because as always we are in for
a treat and headlining that good cash
against Magnus Carlsen what other
matches are you looking forward to well
that's definitely one of the most uh
interesting match and what what I'm
definitely looking forward but let's say
let's say alireza Fabiano I will be also
something
yeah and for you David yeah you stole it
from me Judith
they are the two leaders at the moment
for Rouge and karawana both have won two
classical games impressive uh stuff from
both of them but uh yeah I'm also
interested to see how all the players
bounce back after the rest day because
they have to keep their form going keep
their momentum going and
keep entertaining us hopefully
and what have been your impressions of
the tournament so far
oh I didn't know and I didn't expect
that it will be so good to to watch to
be with you guys and and we are really
making this analysis and fun it's really
entertaining I believe and it is very
interesting for me to see the characters
the players how they are they are
dealing with the problems with the
challenges with losses to see Magnus
coming back and today he had already a
good mood in the studio so he visited to
see Fabi how from round to round he's
developing and he's so calm and to see
the players also in the hotel so this is
something very interesting how the
tournament is developing and for you
David yeah
um I lift up to expectations the
tournament I had high expectations
beforehand seeing such a kind of
eclectic field seeing such kind of
exciting players invited to the
tournament of course the format helps
with that for me it's all about the rest
day as a player I used to hate it as a
commentator I'm grateful but I'm also
looking forward to getting back and yeah
seeing more Fighting Chess I think
that's guaranteed at this point yeah I
think he summed it up beautifully there
David I mean I think the play has been
wonderful a lot of attacking chess and
as the sun sets on another remarkable
day at Norway well we're gonna say
goodbye and see you not tomorrow because
we are taking a rest as are the players
but we will see you on Saturday it will
be the same time 5 p.m Central European
Time and of course thank you all for
watching and I'm gonna wish you goodbye
thank you
foreign